Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pizza Hut in the US and in India.
This is "Food Wars."
The smallest pizza in the US
is the personal pan pizza,
and it is 6 inches across.
In India, our pizzas
start at personal size.
It's seven inches wide
and has four slices.
The US also has a small pizza,
but only with the gluten-free crust,
and it is
difficult.
10 inches wide. So depressing looking.
Then we're on to the mediums.
A medium pizza here in India is 10 inches
and has six slices.
Joe: A US medium pizza
comes in at 12 inches wide.
This medium pizza is equal
to the small pizza in the US.
People in the US, sometimes
it's just really hard
not to stereotype you guys.
Next up in India, we have nothing.
Because medium is our largest size.
That's right, we have only
two sizes, personal or medium.
No large for us because
Pizza Hut is watching our weight, I guess.
Stereotype away, my man,
because in the US, you
know we got this large,
and it is 14 inches in diameter.
So America's largest pizza
is 4 inches wider than India's largest.
That doesn't sound so bad.
However.
If you calculate the surface
area of the two pizzas,
those few inches make a big difference.
The Indian medium has a surface
area of 78.5 square inches,
while the US large clocks
in at 153.9 square inches.
To save you from doing the
math, that's a 96% increase.
That means the US large pizza
is nearly double our Indian medium.
What the heck, Pizza Hut?
The type of crust you get
doesn't affect the width of the pizza,
but how does it affect the value?
We're going to weigh a
medium hand-tossed slice
versus a medium pan-crust slice
to see which one gives you
more pizza for your money.
All right, I'm going to
do the same with our pan
and San Francisco-style
pizzas, the medium size.
All right. So, medium hand-tossed weighs
94 grams.
Pan, the thick boy.
Boy!
Whoa! 104 grams.
That's a difference of --
what was the first one?
That's a difference of this many grams.
This one is pan style,
and it weighs 78 grams.
This slice
weighs 66 grams.
Fairly lighter,
and I think this is because
when they make this pizza,
they press it down into the pan,
and that's the San Francisco style.
This weighs more and therefore is more,
'cause it's more bread.
You want the cheese and the sauce.
You want the fun stuff, right?
I don't -- no.
Oh, boy, this is gonna be trouble.
Here is everything you'll find on the menu
at Pizza Hut India that you
will not find in the US.
And here are all the Pizza
Hut menu items from the US
you won't find in India.
Let's start off with the
foundation of any pizza:
the crust, starting with
the San Francisco signature style.
To my understanding, it's
basically a pan pizza,
but they press the dough
in with their hands
so it's kind of hand-tossed.
Next up, we have something very special.
It's a Schezwan pan pizza.
Oh, my God, yeah. I really like this.
It's spicy. Really yum.
Just to give you some comparison,
the way chicken tikka masala
was invented in the UK
but clearly inspired by Indian cuisine,
Schezwan sauce was actually
invented here in Kolkata
by the Chinese community
that settled down here.
But it's obviously inspired
by Chinese cuisine,
and now it's become
part of Indian cuisine.
We have accepted it wholly,
and we eat it all across India.
Very exciting to see it integrated
into the Pizza Hut menu,
and it actually tastes
very good on this pizza.
Next up they have a
stuffed cheese crust Maxx,
with two X's for emphasis.
You can already see that this
thing is loaded with cheese.
Next to the cheese, alongside it,
there's, like, a sort of creamy sauce,
which Pizza Hut is calling
Peruvian creamy sauce.
Whoa!
Oh, my God, yeah. This is decadent food.
Next up we have a stuffed
crust with veg kebab.
That's right. If you
don't know what kebab is,
it's basically meat that's
cooked in a tandoor.
If you don't know what a tandoor is,
please go watch the older
episodes of "Food Wars."
I've explained it eight times.
A lot of people like to
leave the crust behind,
but I feel like Pizza Hut is making sure
all of the pizza is eaten,
because even this looks
like a dish in itself at this point.
Oh, my God, that's really yum.
And the final option:
the stuffed crust with
a non-vegetarian kebab.
Ooh.
As you can see, this is what
looks to be chicken seekh.
Oh, that's the best of the lot.
That was amazing. Oh, my God.
Smashed it, Pizza Hut.
That might be the best pizza
I've had on "Food Wars" so far,
and I didn't even eat the pizza part.
We also have a variety of
crust options in the US,
starting down here. You saw it already.
Here it is again, the hand-tossed.
This to me is, like,
classic. This is the default.
You guys don't have hand-tossed?
Moving on: Thin 'N Crispy.
I mean, how much -- look at this.
They can't charge the same
amount for this, right?
I don't think they should.
Moving on over here: the
original stuffed crust.
They put cheese in the crust.
Can you believe that?
Ugh, no, it is solidified.
That doesn't stop me from biting into it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Last and, let's be honest,
least: gluten-free crust.
Look, I don't know what's
going on with gluten allergies,
and my apologies if you have
one, but I'm looking at this,
I'm just like, I'm sorry, guys.
I mean, is this that much better?
I don't know how you can enjoy this.
And for a limited time,
Pizza Hut in the US has
Detroit-style pizza!
Let's go! Let us go.
Look at this. Are you
kidding me with this?
Detroit-style pizza. What's Detroit style?
Well, they cook it in a square
pan that has sides to it.
It's like when you cook brownies
and every brownie is
a corner or end piece.
It's like that, for pizza.
So every slice is going to have
the crispy crust on the
outside. It's thicker.
One of my favorite pizza styles.
I'm glad Pizza Hut's doing it.
Generous with the pepperoni,
guys. I appreciate it.
Not the best Detroit-style
pizza I've ever had,
but it's pretty good.
I think they go bread,
cheese, topping, sauce.
These are the toppings we
found under the categories
classic, favorites, and delight.
Very arbitrarily named,
but, yeah, let's jump into it.
The first option is chicken sausage.
Smells really good.
A lot of onions. I love onions.
Mm.
It's pretty classic.
The next pizza is spiced paneer.
Paneer, if you don't
know, is cottage cheese.
We make it all over the
place here in India,
and it's one of our favorite ingredients.
We use it on everything, even pizzas.
Not very spicy,
but definitely it's got,
like, a tangy twist to it.
Next up we have the Veggie Feast.
It's got some herbed onion,
capsicum, and sweet corn.
This is such a wholesome, chill pizza.
It's definitely a classic.
It's something your
mom would make at home.
Next up, we have the veggie tandoori,
which I have already taken a bite of.
We got this one with the Schezwan crust,
so it's definitely spicier
than the typical pan pizza you'll get.
And I already tasted it,
and I told you I loved it.
I love the spice.
Next up, we have spiced
chicken meat-a-balls!
It's a very straightforward pizza,
but we got it with the
cheese-burst filling.
Next up, we have the
Chicken N Corn Delight.
It already has the word
"delight" in the name,
so I'm assuming it should be a delight,
but I'll be the judge of that.
Capsicum; chicken, just
strewn across; and corn.
It's got too much going on, I would say.
Personally, I would not
order a pizza like this.
Next up, to round it all off,
this is the double chicken sausage pizza.
Am I wrong in saying
that this just looks like
a boring version of the
normal chicken sausage pizza,
which has onions and
just feels a lot better?
We have a pepperoni pizza
that is made of pork and not chicken
and a Pepperoni Lover's pizza.
Which one has more pepperoni?
I can't tell!
The supreme pizza.
It has pepperoni, mushrooms,
green peppers, onions,
and that's it.
But if that's not
supreme-y enough for you,
we have the super supreme,
which, now they've
introduced black olives.
Meat Lover's, baby!
Meat Lover's!
You got pepperoni, you got
bacon, you got sausage.
I bet there's something else on there
that I don't know, another meat.
I just, it's beautiful.
This next pizza is the Veggie Lover's,
and I absolutely hate it.
You want veggies? Go get a
salad. Don't put it on pizza.
Like, you're not fooling
anyone, all right?
Backyard barbecue chicken.
Yuelei, do you have enough B-roll?
I think, it's barbecue chicken,
but I think they use barbecue
sauce instead of pizza sauce.
Genius. Genius!
This is so good.
Oh, yeah! The Buffalo chicken.
It's, like, surprisingly good.
Pizza Hut does not have a straight
Hawaiian pizza on the menu.
The only thing they have
is Hawaiian chicken.
I see, obviously, chicken.
I see a pineapple.
I think I see ham? Yep.
I think Hawaiian should
just be pineapple and bacon,
and if you want to throw some
chicken on it that's fine,
but if you have a strong opinion
either for or against pineapple
on pizza, you're wrong.
It's a perfectly fine topping.
I don't know why everyone
gets so worked up about it.
More pizzas, and these are all part
of the signature collection.
There are 11 pizzas in front of me?
Two, four, six ... ah, OK.
First off, the Country Feast.
It looks super saucy.
It's all loaded with vegetables.
There's mushrooms,
capsicum, onion, sweet corn,
roasted peppers; everything that you want
on a country-themed pizza.
All right, next up we
have tandoori paneer.
If you remember in the
previous categories,
we had spiced paneer.
So all I'm looking for
is, why is this different?
Oh, my God, that's really yum.
Next up is the Veggie Lover.
It's basically got
tomato, onion, capsicum,
mushrooms, and some red paprika
and hopefully a whole lot of flavor.
It's underwhelming. I'm gonna be honest.
Next up, we have chicken tikka.
Everybody knows chicken tikka.
It's a bit too strong, too tangy,
and I think they could have gone
with a thinner layer of sauce.
Next up we have the malai chicken tikka.
Malai is basically cream.
So malai kebabs, they
basically grill the chicken
and they pour malai on top.
We have the chicken pepperoni.
Double paneer supreme.
You like paneer? You like Supreme clothes?
Well, this has double of
it, minus the clothes.
Veggie supreme.
Everybody in India has
heard of this pizza.
This is a painting.
I can genuinely see this on
the wall of an art gallery.
There's capsicum, there's
olives, there's corn,
there's onions, there's corn again.
Veg Kebab Surprise.
I'm curious to know what's
gonna be surprising about this.
Surprise, surprise, it tastes bland.
And now on to our
penultimate signature pizza.
This is the chicken tikka supreme!
Woohoo!
Basically what they've
done is they've taken
four different kinds of chicken
and they put it on a pizza.
And finally, in the line
of signature pizzas,
we have Triple Chicken Feast.
It has all of the above ingredients,
and we've also gone the extra mile
and taken it with a chicken
stuffing in the crust.
Overall, Pizza Hut has actually killed it.
I think all the ingredients
have tasted super fresh,
all the meat has also tasted really soft
and juicy and delicious,
and the sauce has been
consistently yum throughout.
Damn, Pizza Hut. Good job.
As mentioned before,
currently have a Detroit-style
pizza at the US Pizza Hut.
This is what it looks like.
Two slices are missing.
I skipped lunch, and
breakfast, to be honest.
For those of you outside
of the United States,
Detroit is a city in Michigan.
They have their own style
of pizza. I really enjoy it.
You can also get it as
a supreme Detroit style
and a meaty deluxe Detroit style.
And I didn't get them
because it all looks exactly like this.
One fun option on the Pizza Hut India menu
is their new range of Momo Mia pizzas,
which are pan pizzas
with momos baked into the crust.
Now, if you don't know what momos are,
they're basically dumplings
from Nepal and Tibet.
They're served all across India,
and they've become huge favorites
for everybody over here.
They've also given a
Schezwan sauce to the side,
which is what you
typically eat with momos.
Hm.
No.
That ain't right. I don't
see how this is working.
I can't think of a single Italian
who would put a pocket of ravioli
on top of pizza and
then bake them together.
And this is effectively what that is.
We also have a range of
Flavour Fun personal pan pizzas
that you can get with
a host of new flavors.
Starting off with classic corn.
Next up, we have the
classic onion and capsicum.
Tandoori mushroom and corn.
So, it looks similar to this,
but it used tandoori sauce
and the varied mushrooms.
Next up, we have the classic
paneer, onion, and capsicum.
Then we have the classic chicken sausage,
but personal-pan-sized.
Next, we have the Italian
pepperoni and onion.
And just a reminder that the pepperoni
that they've used is chicken pepperoni.
Tandoori chicken tikka and onion,
and the classic loaded chicken delight.
Personally, [crickets chirping]
I wouldn't order these pans.
I would get the larger pizzas,
'cause they tasted way better.
On top of set menu items,
we can also customize our
pizzas in unique ways.
For example, if you don't want
tomato sauce as your base,
you can sub it out for
creamy garlic Parmesan,
barbecue sauce, remember from before?
Buffalo sauce, or a no-sauce option
if you are a maniac.
And if you want you can specify light,
regular, or extra sauce.
Unfortunately, we can't change the sauces
on our pizza bases,
but we have a bunch of custom toppings
that you will not find in the US,
like baby corn, sweet
corn, herbed veggies,
spiced paneer, and veg kebab.
And we also have exclusive toppings
you cannot get in India.
For instance, we have
pepperoni, which is pork;
our Italian sausage has pork;
bacon, ah, I believe is pork;
meatballs, beef and pork;
ham, pork;
and then beef;
and pork.
Then the vegetables: We got white onion;
we got pineapple, which is a fruit;
and we have banana
peppers, which I don't know
if it's a fruit or a
vegetable or a pepper.
Are peppers fruit?
Whenever we have the
option of customizations
on "Food Wars," we like
to combine all of our
exclusive ingredients to
make an India-only pizza.
So this pizza has a Schezwan
base with baby corn,
veg kebab, spiced paneer,
and herbed veggies.
It looks pretty gnarly, I'm not gonna lie,
but let's see how it tastes.
Hm.
I can see why Pizza Hut didn't put this
officially on their menu,
'cause maybe the ingredients
don't go that well together,
but, hey, this is an
India-only Pizza Hut pizza,
and that means something.
And, of course, we had to
create our own US-only pizza.
So, the thin crispy base,
creamy garlic Parmesan sauce,
beef, bacon, white onion,
and everyone's favorite
vegetable, banana peppers.
No!
This looks like a cartoon pizza.
Ah.
OK, it's not bad.
It's not great. I wouldn't get it.
Yeah, it tastes like onion and bacon.
Don't get this.
Oop!
Pizza Hut has a bunch of sides.
So, let's start off with the breads.
First off, we have cheese garlic bread.
Then we have spicy supreme
cheese garlic bread.
It's basically cheese melted
on top of a garlic bread baguette.
It's got some green chili
and some chopped onions.
It's very delicious when it's hot.
Mexican garlic breadsticks.
Oregano sprinkled on top,
some jalapeño, some
chopped olives, and onions.
It looks really delicious.
Creamy garlic breadsticks.
And finally we have garlic
breadsticks in a little packet
that says "GARLIC BREAD STIX."
The US Pizza Hut only offers
regular breadsticks and cheese sticks.
So, in fact, the only
actual exclusive side
that we have in the US is fries.
We have a bunch of other sides,
including baked cheesy momos veg
and baked cheesy momos non-veg.
Whew. That's a potent smell.
You know what?
It's not half bad.
Next up we have potato poppers,
which are pretty much Tater Tots.
We have the Indi Rockin Roll veg
and the Indi Rockin Roll non-veg.
This is basically a roll,
but I like how the wrap is kind of thin.
Again, it's quite good.
Next up, we have the zesty paneer pocket
and the zesty chicken pocket.
These are pretty much like pizza pockets.
There's some mint mayo, some
normal mayo, some cream cheese,
chicken, and jalapeños.
We have jalapeño poppers.
I imagine they're just filled with cheese
and some jalapeño bits.
Oh, ugh, I did not
expect that consistency.
And that brings us to an
old classic: chicken wings.
Spicy baked chicken wings.
So I suppose they're a
healthier alternative?
WingStreet wings.
Yes!
Both traditional and boneless.
You can get them in the following flavors.
Lemon pepper. Oh, let's go, lemon pepper.
I usually don't like lemon pepper,
but these are pretty good.
Ooh, honey barbecue.
Ugh, these things are like condensation.
Ah, ooh, the medium Buffalo.
Ooh, Cajun style!
Eh, just OK.
Spicy garlic. What?
Naked. That's wings with nothing on it.
Why would you do that? I don't know.
Buffalo Burnin' Hot.
Three flames!
Mm, this should be your medium.
Oh, wait!
Yeah, OK.
Sweet chili.
Am I sweating? I feel like I'm sweating.
They're all just eh. You
know, I mean, I like wings.
Maybe my wing standards are too high.
Garlic Parmesan. Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
[sighs]
Oh, my God!
I mean, the sauce is like
pasta sauce. It's really thick.
It's got a lot of flavor to it,
but it's just, like, sitting in the sauce,
so either you get a
mouthful of sauce or none.
And these come in portions
of six, 12, 18, or 36.
And next up on the menu,
you can also find a range of pastas,
starting with the creamy mushroom.
[sauce squishing]
You know what? If I have to
listen to this, so will you all.
[sauce squishing]
Just get some in the boom mic.
Decent pasta for a fast-food restaurant.
They have a cheesy comfort veg pasta
and a cheesy comfort chicken pasta.
It's too gooey.
We have the spiced Tomato Twist veg pasta
and the spiced Tomato Twist non-veg pasta.
If you come to Pizza Hut to order pasta,
I hope we never cross paths.
Nikhil, you have no idea.
We absolutely love our
carbs in this country.
And as you can see,
we have bowls and bowls of
carbs that we call pasta.
You can get four exclusive
oven-baked pastas
at pa -- pasta hut. At Pizza Hut.
I'm not eating any of these.
They all taste terrible.
All right? The end.
You can get a oven-baked
chicken Alfredo. Don't get this.
Or, if you don't like chicken,
you can just get cheesy Alfredo.
And then, of course, we have
the Italian meats pasta,
which is pepperoni and Italian sausage.
I mean, oh, Italy. Oh, Italy.
I'm so sorry.
And, lastly, the oven-baked veggie pasta.
I mean, this is a doorstop.
I can't stand the Pizza Hut pasta.
I cannot stand it.
You see the sauces. You
know what time it is.
Sauce talk.
Starting down here, get
yourself blue cheese sauce,
then get ranch.
Ooh, a garlic sauce.
We can have a honey barbecue sauce,
a medium Buffalo sauce,
and a side of marinara,
just for dipping your breadsticks.
And also icing, the Cinnabon
icing for the Cinnabuns.
And there's a note that says,
"I really want to see Joe dipping
some pizza in the frosting
and eat it."
[sighs]
Give me this.
Oh!
Actually ...
At first I was like, yuck,
but this is kind of good.
And now on to dips. You dips---s.
First off, we have tomato ketchup. Ha ha.
[crew laughing]
Then we have a mayonnaise.
Fun fact: It's veg mayonnaise,
doesn't have any egg, because a huge
population of this country
is pure vegetarians,
which means that they don't eat anything
from an animal, even egg.
Then we have a cheese dip.
And finally, it's a Schezwan sauce.
And they serve it with the momos,
they serve it with a
bunch of other things.
Yeah.
We got desserts you're
not gonna find in India.
That includes, down here,
the cinnamon sticks.
They're like breadsticks, only cinnamony.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho.
Get your mind out of the gutter.
And moving on, we have here are the
Cinnabon mini cinnamon rolls.
This is the triple chocolate brownie.
If I had to guess, 2 pounds.
What do we got here? The
ultimate chocolate chip cookie.
Right?
This is like a Frisbee.
And for all you sweetie pies
out there with sweet tooths,
here are India's exclusive desserts,
starting with a choco lava cake, baby!
Ooh!
Molten.
The choco lava cake in
Domino's? Much better.
Next up, you get a whole
range of ice cream.
Some Kwality Wall's,
one of India's biggest
ice cream manufacturers.
You can get a tiny tub of
Choco-Tastic Supreme Sundae.
Then you can get a Cornetto, a cone.
Super delicious. And I
really love the end of this,
because it's just a block of chocolate,
and I used to fight over
this with my friends.
Then you get a Magnum.
Everybody loves a Magnum.
And finally, you can even get
a family pack of ice cream.
Soda!
Last exclusive are, of course, the drinks.
Both countries have Pepsi,
but the Pizza Hut in the US
you can also get wild
cherry Pepsi, orange Crush,
Mountain Dew, baby!
Sierra Mist, which they didn't have,
and Aquafina.
Here in Pizza Hut India,
our exclusive drink options
are Pepsi, 7Up, Mirinda, and Pepsi black.
They also serve an iced
tea at the restaurant,
but they don't deliver it, unfortunately.
I would've gone for the iced tea.
All right, now let's take a
look at Pizza Hut's pricing,
particularly some clever marketing tricks
they're using to make you
believe you're getting
more value for money
than you actually are.
In the US, a medium cheese
pizza on the pan crust
will cost you $13.49.
In India, a medium Margherita
pizza will cost you
319 rupees, which is
currently 3.93 US dollars.
That means over here you
are paying 11.9 cents
per square inch of pizza.
While over here in India,
you're just paying 4.4 cents
per square inch of pizza.
That makes the US pizza
170% more expensive.
Generally with pizza, the more you buy,
the cheaper it gets.
A US large has a surface
area of 153.9 square inches
and costs $15.49.
That brings the cost per
square inch down to 10 cents,
making it 15% cheaper than the medium.
Ladies and gentlemen, it's
time for pizza pop quiz!
Which has the higher surface area,
one medium pizza or two personal pizzas?
If you said two personal
pizzas, congratulations!
You're an idiot.
Because when it comes to
calculating the surface area
of a circle, small changes in diameter
can create huge differences
in surface area.
On the Pizza Hut India website,
you can get a combo offer
of two personal pan pizzas for rupees 279.
However, a medium pizza
costs pretty much the same.
But I guess if you want two
different flavors of pizza,
it makes sense to go with the combo.
In this medium cheese pan-crust pizza,
it is 1,940 calories,
79 grams of total fat, 33
grams of saturated fat,
224 grams of carbs, and
the sodium, oh, boy,
3,480 milligrams.
A medium Margherita pizza
in India will cost you
1,377 calories,
total fat 40.29 grams,
of which saturates are 14.7 grams,
carbohydrates, 192 grams,
and 2,717 milligrams of sodium.
Yikes.
Now, the American stats look a lot worse,
but I do want to point out that our medium
is much larger than India's.
So if you break it down per square inch,
you'll see that the US version
does have more fat and more saturated fat,
but India's pizza actually contains
more calories, carbs, and sodium.
But what about the most calorific
item on the Indian menu?
If you really want to mess up your day,
you have to order the medium
veg Surprise Kebab pizza
with veg-kebab-stuffed crust.
A whole one of these pizzas will contain
2,673 calories.
That's 133.65% of your daily
caloric-intake allowance.
Oh, my God.
OK, the calories are high,
but the sodium is even higher.
There is 6,344 milligrams
of sodium in here,
which is 275% of your daily
recommended allowance.
What about the most calorific
pizza in the US, you ask?
Well, that would be a large
pan-crusted Meat Lover's,
which this isn't.
So imagine it bigger and thicker. OK.
An entire one of these contains a whopping
3,570 calories.
That's 178% of your daily allowance.
And the sodium is even
worse than that of India's.
There's 7,150 milligrams
of sodium in here.
That is 298%
your daily recommended amount.
Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Dunkin' Donuts
in India and in the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in the US, you can get your doughnuts
in one; six, or a half dozen;
or 12, aka a dozen.
Don't put that in there.
Here in India, you can get your doughnuts
in packs of one, three, or six.
One US sticky glazed doughnut.
Nikhil: Indian glazed doughnut.
Joe: It weighs ...
Nikhil: 49 grams.
Joe: 59 grams.
In the US, we have four
sizes of hot coffee.
The small, the medium, the large,
which, unfortunately, they forgot.
Dunkin'!
And the extra large.
Here in India, our filter coffee
comes in one size, this one.
If you're wondering what filter coffee is,
it's one of the most popular
drinks here in India.
It's made by taking a decoction of coffee,
mixing it with sweetened milk,
and typically when they're preparing it,
they pour it from a huge
height to create this froth.
It's super delicious,
and it's very strong.
It'll wake you right up in the morning.
As for our other drinks,
they come in two sizes.
Either medium or large.
This is an Americano.
Let's weigh it to see how much we got.
I might have to go to
the bathroom after this.
10.14 fluid ounces.
If that's not enough for you,
Dunkin's in the US also has a Box 'O Joe,
which contains 100 ounces of hot coffee.
And ...
[groaning]
Guzh!
Oh, yeah.
This should be the extra large.
In the US, we "only" have
three iced-coffee sizes.
The small, the medium, and the large.
No extra large, but they did remember
the large iced coffee,
so, thanks, Dunkin'.
So, the Dunkin' India website says
that they serve an iced Americano.
But we asked three
outlets here in Bengaluru,
and they said no iced Americano.
We even asked them,
"Hey, can you put some
ice in our Americano?"
They said no.
So if you really must have an Americano
that's iced from Dunkin',
you have to take your
own ice and go there.
So, what's the large?
Is this supposed to be 32?
I mean, I think it's --
Yeah, cup says 32, it's supposed to be 32.
Yuelei, zoom in on that
and shame this business!
32?
This is everything that
you'll find on the menu
at Dunkin' Donuts India that
you will not find in the US.
Here is everything you can
get in a US Dunkin' Donuts
you can't get in India.
Let's start off with this
one. It is called Choco Villa.
And I think it's called that
because there's a little
triangle of chocolate,
which looks like those houses
we used to draw as kids.
Oh, my God.
Yum!
It's filled with my favorite
doughnut filling ever,
which is Bavarian cream.
Choco almond.
Hm, it's OK.
It's filled with the Bavarian cream again.
With the cream, unreal.
On to the next one. This
is called a Chocoholic.
It's got a piece of KitKat
sticking through it.
I want to see if it's one KitKat
bar or if they've taken two
and they've sandwiched them together.
Let's pull from this end.
Yeah, I was right.
If you're a chocoholic,
this is the one for you.
The inside has also got
chocolaty filling in there.
Chocolate is starting to
hit me real hard right now.
This stuff is so sweet.
This is called Rainbow Crunch.
Oh.
There's strawberry frosting on top.
So this has a strawberry taste.
It's OK. It's a doughnut.
Next up, we have Cookie Delight.
It's called Cookie Delight
'cause they've taken cookie
powder and smacked it on top.
This one's called Crispy Crunch.
For people who have trypophobia,
this one is probably not for you.
Oh, my God, this ain't it.
The crispy stuff on top
is just not working.
Again, however, they do have
the Bavarian cream inside --
I feel like there's a hurricane
inside my body right now.
Next up, we have a
doughnut called the Gemmy.
My fellow Indians will recognize
that there are gems on top.
This is one of the most nostalgic
chocolates here in India,
and I've eaten them since I was a kid.
Super yum.
You'd think a kid would like them,
but I can't even imagine
a kid version of myself
liking something that's so overdosed
with sweetness and chocolate.
Is it Gemmy? Yes.
Too Gemmy? Also yes.
I'd avoid.
So, I thought this was all
the exclusive signatures,
but I've been told that
there are two more.
And let's start off with this
one. It's called Choco Pop.
It's got chocolate on
top, chocolate sprinkles,
chocolate wavy line things,
and it's filled with chocolate.
It's very sweet.
Ah.
Whew!
All right.
And on to our last doughnut.
This one is called the Choco Berry Bomb.
That's actually quite nice.
It has definitely cut the
sweetness that I've experienced.
There's, like, some berry jam inside,
which is kind of tart and nice.
The top is milk chocolate with
shavings of white chocolate.
Whew!
Yeah, it's a good doughnut.
I wouldn't order it. It's too much.
All of this, I would
not order any of these.
They're too much.
Exclusive doughnuts you can get in the US
you can't get in India.
Now, we're filming this
the first week of October.
Of course, the No. 1 flavor
you get this month is pumpkin.
Mm, so pumpkiny.
Yeah, this tastes just like pumpkin pie.
Also, you can get yourself
a glazed blueberry doughnut.
See? Look at that.
Glaze on top, blueberry
dough on the inside.
Also delicious. Love it.
Glazed chocolate. Figured
this was everywhere, right?
So good.
Ooh, Boston cream.
The Ben Affleck of doughnuts.
Looks like a regular doughnut,
doesn't it, everyone in India?
But
surprise, there's cream on the inside!
I know everyone likes doughnuts,
maybe I haven't had a doughnut in a while,
but crap, this is really good.
One of my favorites.
I f--- with these.
Double chocolate, maybe my favorite,
'cause they just did what they had to do.
Take a chocolate doughnut and
put that chocolate frosting
I like right on top of
it. A double threat.
Oh, these are so good.
I am in heaven!
A strawberry frosting with sprinkles?
You don't got this?
This is, like, the Homer
Simpson doughnut, right?
This is the one that you
always see him eating.
Oh, the vanilla cream.
Gotta say, don't think I've
ever had this one before.
Look at me.
It's like "Scarface" over
here. I'm just covered.
A little much.
Ugh! Ugh!
Oh, God.
Here's some powder right here.
Powdered doughnut.
India, you don't know what this is?
C'mon. It's, like, doughnut No. 1, right?
Also in the US you can get a
vanilla frosted with sprinkles,
and a bear claw, which they
unfortunately did not have
at the time of shooting this.
Anyway, ah.
Munchkins? You guys don't got Munchkins?
What?
We have a variety of Munchkin flavors,
but this one specifically
is the pumpkin Munchkin,
and,
mm!
Tastes just like pumpkin pie. Fantastic.
Hey, guys, we're now on to a
different category of doughnuts
called the all-time favorites.
I took a quick hospital visit,
and I'm completely fine now.
I'm sorry about the madness
from the previous set of doughnuts.
I'm fine now. I don't
know what came over me.
OK, so we'll start off with
this specimen over here.
It's called a Cookie Cartwheel.
Adorable name, and, yes,
it does look like a wheel.
I like how they put the white stripes.
Yeah.
It's sweet.
Next up on our list is a doughnut
that's not intimidating at all,
it's only called Death by Chocolate.
Will this kill me?
Probably not.
But will this give me some
diabetes if I eat too much?
Absolutely.
And for that reason,
it's a win in my book.
If you thought Death
by Chocolate was scary,
this is Alive by Chocolate.
In terms of visual
differences, I can already tell
this one has more of a
cookie crumble on top.
They're very similar, as expected.
I will say, this one, it feels more, like,
it lifts your spirits
and you feel more alive.
And this one will probably
put you to sleep, in a coma.
So death and alive, it makes sense.
[ears ringing]
Mm, whoa!
On to the next one. We
have something called
Very Very Strawberry.
Vanilla frosting on top,
it's got some pink streaks,
and it looks to be stuffed
with strawberry jam.
Which sounds amazing,
especially after all
this chocolate overdose.
It's sweet.
Oh, my God.
It's nice, though.
All right, it's time
for our final doughnut,
and this one is a bit of a boss battle.
So, this is a doughnut eclair.
It's called the Breakup Party Eclair.
I guess because if you
go through a breakup,
this is what you end up eating.
So, the first few bites were quite nice.
They weren't as sweet, and
they didn't feel as rich.
But I realized most of the
chocolate is kind of centered
towards the center of the eclair.
And so it's a lot more
decadent the closer you get.
Great for breakups, great as
a metaphor for what you feel
when you're going through a breakup,
and as a doughnut itself, pretty average.
Both hot and cold espresso
and coffee drinks in the US
have options for flavors
you can add as flavor shots,
which are unsweetened,
or flavor swirls, which
are sweet and creamy.
Now, flavors unique to
the US include shots of
vanilla, toasted almond, blueberry,
raspberry, and coconut.
And flavor swirls, you can get
French vanilla and pumpkin.
So, I went ahead and had each
one of those swirls and shots
added to one coffee,
right here in front of me.
We'll call it the Food Wars DrinkAroo.
I don't know what it is.
All the flavors in one drink.
The lady when I ordered
it was like, "Really?"
And I was like, "Really."
Oh, God, this is so bad.
Oh, ugh!
Just blegh. Whoa!
Oh, man.
[exhales sharply]
It's like, there's, like,
an electric charge to it
at the end I don't quite understand.
Mm.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
This is poison. Don't get it.
All right, it's time for drinks.
Let's start off with the cold options
that we have here at Dunkin' India.
The first one is a classic lemonade.
Let's go ahead and try it.
It looks very clear.
That was nice. Refreshing.
They have not made it too
sweet, and I kind of like it.
Next up, we have a virgin mojito.
I don't see why somebody
would go to Dunkin' Donuts,
get a doughnut, and then a
virgin mojito on the side.
Quick point to make: You can
get them in a small bottle,
or you can even get
them in larger options.
Next up, we have two flavors of iced tea.
We have lemon and peach.
I'm going to try the peach.
If I had to pick one of these,
this is the one I'd go for.
Exclusive hot drinks here in
the US, we have these three.
The first one is, like, a
specific coffee blend at Dunkin'
called Dunkin' Midnight.
Oh, wow, that has,
[stammers] that's strong.
Wow.
It's, like, really
strong. I kinda love it.
Moving on, you can get
yourself a chai latte.
India doesn't have chai
lattes? What's going on, guys?
That's really good.
And, of course, a matcha latte.
No, not matcha.
I hate matcha.
That's the green one, right?
Beverages that taste like lawn clippings.
Mm-mm.
Ugh. I hate it.
All right, it's now
time for our milk-based
cold beverages here in India.
We have a range of frappés,
some iced shaken coffees.
Let's start with the frappés.
Coffee, caramel, and hazelnut.
And they have a seasonal
flavor, which is Alphonso mango.
If you've not heard of the
Alphonso variety of mangoes,
it grows all over here in India,
and it is the king of mangoes.
You have to try it if you get a chance.
I'm going to start off with this one,
because I love mango-flavored anything.
It's not bad.
Next up, we have some shaken iced coffees
in three flavors, caramel,
classic, and hazelnut.
Also the classic flavored
shaken iced coffee,
it's not as sweet, and I want
to put this one on a pedestal.
Thank you.
OK, next up, they also sell a
iced mocha and an iced latte.
It's time for the chocolate milkshake,
and can I just say, looks decadent.
It's quite thick. It's kind of grainy.
Like, you can taste the
graininess of the chocolate,
which I like, but I don't know,
some people might not like that.
Some people might like really
smooth chocolate milkshakes.
OK, so if you're traveling to India
and you must eat at Dunkin',
I would recommend you have
the Alphonso mango
frappé if it's in season.
But I would also say, don't go to Dunkin',
go to any juice shop, you'll
find them all across India,
and they take fresh mangoes,
and they make you a mango milkshake
that will blow your mind.
They'll put actual pieces
of Alphonso pulp in there,
and you'll chew on it while
you drink your milkshake.
Godsends.
Joe: So, they made these
two hours ago. I'm sorry.
Assume they don't look like this.
Anyway, we have these
cold drinks in the US.
They're called refreshers.
They're actually pretty
good, surprisingly.
Starting down here, we have
the strawberry dragon fruit.
I am such a child. It's spelled
S-T-R-A-W-D-R-G-N-F-R-T,
and all I could think
of was "dragon fart."
Wow, that's actually pretty good.
Peach passion fruit.
[laughing] F-R-T.
I keep thinking "fart." I'm such a child.
[fart tooting]
Whoa! Blegh! What the hell?
I think all the syrup went to the bottom.
It's way stronger than it should be.
Yeah, 'cause up top it's really weak.
Somewhere between there's a
good sip, but I didn't find it.
Anyway, all right.
Peach passion fruit coconut.
Oh, well this is -- is
that cool? Does that work?
OK.
Ah, no.
Oh, gross. Yeah.
The coconut ones are bad.
Keeping it up on the cool drinks,
you can get yourself a frozen coffee,
a frozen matcha latte, a frozen chocolate,
and, of course, the Coolattas.
Wait, frozen hot chocolate?
Isn't that just chocolate milk?
Oh, man, that is strong.
That is a milkshake.
Yo.
It's not terrible. The
flavor is very strong.
This is apparently a blue raspberry.
Think they have other flavors, but.
Once upon a time, I
worked at a movie theater.
Yes, really.
But we figured out a way
to get into the syrup box,
'cause fountain drinks,
it's syrup and soda water
at the same time, and it mixes
right when you pour it in.
It was a really dark color,
and we dared each other to drink it.
I remember it was so powerful,
I thought I was gonna throw up.
And I never experienced anything
that powerful-flavored, until today.
Surprise, surprise.
Dunkin' Donuts also sells chai.
So, you have two flavors,
this is ginger chai,
and we have elaichi chai.
Elaichi is cardamom.
Ginger in Hindi is adrak.
And it's just such a beautiful
word to say, oh, my God!
Adrak chai!
Oof, they've gone heavy
on the ginger for sure.
As advertised, these do taste like
elaichi, which is cardamom, and ginger.
Yeah, they don't quite have the soul
of a chai that you get on the roadside,
but I really love how
Dunkin' has tried to do this.
Makes you feel a little bit more at home,
so thank you, Dunkin'.
Sandwiches, and wraps, and
bagels, and breakfast stuff.
Oh. My.
Get a good look, India.
We have a huge selection
of non-doughnut-y breakfast sandwiches,
variety stuff you can get.
Oh, man, I hit a wall, and I apologize.
And I'm back.
You can get yourself maple
sugar bacon breakfast sandwich.
We have these Wake-Up Wraps,
and Wake-Up Wraps are,
I don't know, really
phoned-in breakfast tacos.
I don't know how else to describe it.
It's a tortilla. They put
the stuff they already had
for the other sandwiches in there.
They fold it over.
I'll just grab one. You
can get yourself one,
and oh, man, this thing is like ...
[glass shattering]
Hey, everyone watching this video,
in the comments, let me know:
I show you this, and then when I open it,
are you more likely to
eat this or less likely?
Let me know in the comments.
Dunkin', nobody wants these.
You can get yourself a
tomato pesto grilled cheese.
Pesto's fine and all, but
when something has pesto on it
and you don't realize it,
doesn't this look like --
like, look at this green.
Does that look like,
would you go, "Oh, it's pesto,"
or would you be like, "Ugh,
I think that's moldy"?
Also got the grilled cheese.
Oh!
[gavel thuds]
Then you get yourself a
sourdough breakfast sandwich.
Yo, these things solidified.
Probably edible a few hours ago.
I'll take a bite of this.
Sausage, egg, and cheese.
Yeah, not bad.
Bacon, egg, and cheese.
Somewhere encased in this
melted cheese is bacon,
I assure you.
There's also a turkey sausage,
egg, and cheese somewhere.
Oh, you can also get bagels
at your Dunkin' Donuts.
Why? I don't know.
But you can get your bagels plain,
cinnamon raisin, multigrain,
sesame seed, and this one, everything.
And you can get yourself
some cream cheeses,
including garden veggie,
strawberry, and plain.
Also you can get an avocado spread,
which they did not include.
Dunkin'!
India, you're not gonna believe this.
Our Dunkin' Donuts, you
can get a side of, [laughs]
you can get a side of something
called snackin' bacon.
What's snackin' bacon, you ask?
It is a bag of bacon.
Bagel minis.
You can get plain and everything bagels.
Here's one right now.
I think these have cream
cheese inside of them.
Yeah.
I don't think I've ever
had one of these before.
That's not a bad idea.
Not bad, guys.
Also in the US, you can get
an order of hash browns.
Now, at Dunkin' Donuts,
apparently you can get these,
what do we call these?
Omelet bites?
You get bacon, egg, and cheese
or egg white and veggie.
C'mon. This is straight
taken from Starbucks, right?
We went to the Dunkin' India
website, and over there,
on the menu, they claim to sell burgers
and a few sides, like nachos.
However, we went to the outlets,
and the managers said
that they're phasing out
all savory food in Dunkin' nationally.
But he was kind enough to make us
one single non-veg burger,
just so that we get to taste
what it would've been like.
It has a whole chicken piece in there,
which is already kind of nice.
Some onions, what looks
like tandoori mayo,
and the bun. Looks pretty tasty.
Oh, my God.
That's actually really good.
I've done many episodes of "Food Wars,"
tasted many burgers from restaurants
that are literally burger joints,
and this literally rivals those burgers.
This is pretty good.
What's happening, Dunkin'?
OK, so, the fact is that
Dunkin' has actually
scaled down massively here in India.
In Bengal, where we're filming,
there used to be 20 Dunkin' Donut outlets.
Now there are only three.
So rumor has it that Dunkin' might be
phasing out of India in general,
and the decision is going to
be made in the coming weeks.
So maybe this video is
the last remaining legacy
of Dunkin' in India.
And this is probably the last
burger that is ever eaten.
Oh, dude, this might be the --
guys, this might be the
last burger ever consumed
from Dunkin' Donuts here in India.
OK, let's talk price.
This large Americano is rupees 139,
which is currently $1.71.
But keep in mind, at the
time that we're filming this,
the Indian rupee is at an all-time low,
so hopefully things will get better
and this won't cost so much.
That same drink in the US is $3.69,
or 293.44 rupees.
That's a 63.9% increase in price.
OK, so the biggest menu item
that we have here in India
is our box of six.
Now, you can get two categories.
You can get classic doughnuts,
which are a lot simpler,
and it'll cost you rupees 399.
Or you can get the favorites doughnuts,
which we have here, which
are a lot more extravagant
and will cost you rupees 499,
which amounts to USD 6.12 right now.
If you want 12 doughnuts, you
need to get two boxes of six,
which will cost you rupees 998.
For food, our biggest menu
item is a dozen doughnuts.
$18.73,
or 1,492.85 rupees.
Thank you.
Our biggest drink is
the Box O' Joe Avella.
It's the most expensive single menu item.
$27.48,
or 2,190.25 rupees.
Now, in India we have
something called a vada,
which is pretty much a doughnut,
but it's savory and it's fried.
And I want to say that
those cost around 20 rupees,
while this original glazed
that I've bitten into a few times
costs 85 rupees.
So, it's important to know
this price difference,
and people here will
definitely think about that
before buying something like this.
Nikhil, stop eating the props!
OK, so Dunkin' Donuts
India has not released
any of their nutritional
info out for the public.
And they've not gotten back to us
when we asked them for
information, as of now.
However, I can confirm that one doughnut
is probably less
nutritious than one salad.
Let's talk about Dunkin' US nutrition,
starting with the glazed doughnut.
In the US, it has 360 calories,
22 grams of fat,
10 grams of saturated fat,
420 milligrams of sodium --
420.
39 grams of carbs,
and 18 grams of sugar.
And let's compare that
doughnut to this one,
the Boston cream.
In the USA, a Boston
cream is 270 calories,
11 grams of fat,
320 milligrams of sodium,
39 grams of carbs,
and 18 grams of sugar.
Dunkin' Donuts large iced
Dunkin' dark-roast coffee
with cream and sugar, in the US,
is 260 calories,
12 grams of fat,
and 37 grams of carbs.
Now, assuming that the iced coffee
is the same in the US and India,
getting a large iced
coffee with cream and sugar
and both the glazed and
a Boston cream doughnut
is 890 calories.
That's 35.6% of your daily calorie intake.
Yo.
Again, Dunkin' Donuts has not released
any of their ingredients to the public.
However, there is one huge difference
between the US and Indian doughnuts,
and that is that the Indian
doughnuts are all eggless.
This is because a huge percentage
of Indians are vegetarian,
especially Hindus, and so
they even consider eating egg
as non-veg food, and so, yeah.
Most fast-food restaurants
have decided to not use egg
in any of their foods to
make it more accessible
to a larger part of India.
But the US does have it on its site,
so we'll share with you
the ingredients right now.
First up, the coffee.
Regardless of getting it hot or cold,
if you get it black, it's going
to be 100% arabica coffee.
Nice. Now,
if you want to add cream and sugar to it,
then you are adding milk, cream,
disodium phosphate as a stabilizer,
sodium citrate as a stabilizer, and sugar.
If you're going to be adding
flavor to your coffee drink,
one flavor you can get in both
India and the US is caramel.
And in the US, our caramel
flavor is made up of all this.
In the US, our standard glazed doughnut
is made up of all of these things.
You think that's a lot?
Here's everything in our
Boston cream doughnuts.
Yikes, that's a lot of words.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Nando's in the UK and India.
This is "Food Wars."
If you're ordering chicken for one person,
it comes in three sizes at a UK Nando's.
As a quarter chicken,
as a half chicken,
or as a whole chicken.
Chicken for one person
here at Nando's India
comes in the form of
a quarter chicken, which is one piece,
or a half chicken, which is two pieces.
You can also get a whole chicken,
but it only comes in the
form of a sharing platter,
the largest of which is a jumbo platter,
two whole chickens and five large sides.
I'm excited to eat this, but
all I need now is friends,
so hit me up.
The largest item in the
UK is the family platter.
It comes with two whole chickens
as well as five large sides.
Family of one.
I could eat this.
What about some other things
from the Nando's menu?
Well, in the UK, you can
get a grilled chicken burger
in two sizes.
As a single or as a double.
Nando's India also sells chicken burgers
and offers customers the
option to double their chicken,
so you can get a single chicken burger
or double it to a double chicken burger.
Nando's India serves chicken wings,
but only in one size, a pack of four.
Wings from a UK Nando's
come in four portion sizes:
as a three-piece,
as a five-piece,
as a 10-piece,
and a 15-piece.
It's really weird being the country
with the bigger sizes for a change.
Joe, I miss you.
Now, the classic side for any
order of Nando's in the UK
is a side of peri-peri chips.
I'm allowed to call them chips, not fries,
because Joe is not in this video.
In the UK, these come in two sizes,
regular and large.
Here at Nando's India,
they're advertised not
as chips but as fries,
because that's what they
are, Harry, you weirdo.
I'm going to weigh them.
You get them in two sizes,
either regular or large.
Let me weigh the regular.
It's 100 grams on the dot. Nice.
Next.
418 grams.
No, 408 grams.
175 grams in the large.
I don't know how to read.
Here is everything on
the menu at a UK Nando's
that you won't find in India.
This is everything you'll find
on the menu at Nando's India
that you will not find in the UK.
We'll start with the chicken.
Now, when you order chicken at Nando's,
they'll ask you to pick a spice level.
We have quite a few of these,
most of which are shared
with India, except for two.
Firstly, we have pimento spice.
I think this is limited edition,
and it sits somewhere
between medium and hot
on the spice scale.
And our other exclusive
spice is peri tamer.
As the name suggests, this
is quite a mild, tame spice.
It sits somewhere between mild
and basically plain chicken.
I think it's a slightly sweeter glaze
than you might find on the
regular peri-peri spice.
Here in India, we just get our chicken
in the classic scale of plain,
lemon and herb, mild,
hot, and extra hot.
I'm willing to bet that our extra hot
blows the UK extra hot out of the water.
You see this tongue?
This tongue can take spice.
Oh, my God, is this some kind of joke?
It's, like, tickling me.
It's teasing me with spice.
This is child's play.
I will say, I love how the UK
Nando's has two extra flavors.
I wish India Nando's experimented more.
We're in India, dude!
There are so many spices!
But what we lack in spices,
we make up for in mains.
No. 1, creamy cashew
chicken with spicy rice.
Damn good.
OK, now on to the next main.
This is chicken cataplana.
Cataplana is a type of Portuguese
clam-shaped ... stove? Cooking pot?
And they've also served
it with a yogurt dip.
So using a cataplana
is apparently healthier
because you end up using less fats
to cook your meat and your veggies.
Next up, we're having chicken espetada,
or, as I like to call
it, chicken espe ta-da!
I've been fired from this
show 16 times this season.
I imagine they take the pieces of chicken,
put them on skewers, put the marinade.
So, Nando's is a Portuguese-inspired
South African restaurant,
so most of the recipes are
things that were developed
by Portuguese explorers when
they were in South Africa.
We also have a lot of
cuisine that's inspired
by our former colonial
overlords back in Portugal.
In fact, Goa, which is our
smallest state here in India,
was where the Portuguese first settled,
and so a lot of the cuisine is derived
and inspired by Portuguese cuisine.
We have a couple of
chicken mains of our own,
starting with boneless thighs.
These come in orders of
four, and you can get them
in any of the standard
Nando's spice levels.
And our other chicken exclusive is this,
wing roulette.
So, wing roulette is an order of 10 wings,
and it's a variety of the Nando's spices.
The idea is that you'll get some of these,
share them with your friends,
some of you might get hit
with an extra-hot wing,
whereas others might get
off easy with a mild.
When I go to Nando's, I'm
generally going for medium or hot.
I'm not trying to be a hero.
If I'm going for extra hot,
I'm just not actually
going to taste the food.
It's just going to kind of hurt.
I may also add a little bit
of the garlic and herb sauce,
which adds a little bit of spice to it,
or also I've used ketchup in the past,
which my friends have lambasted
me for, so don't do that.
Good chicken, though.
We also have some meal deals.
These are more affordable options,
and you will not find them in the UK.
Let's start off with the first one,
which is pulled-chicken sliders.
Oh, my God, this is like gourmet dining.
I think I would need to eat three of these
to feel considerably full.
Unfortunately, they only give you two.
Next up is a pulled-chicken burger.
Oh, my. Mother lode of chicken.
That is a lot of pulled chicken.
It needs a sauce.
Did I just eat a part
that doesn't have sauce?
Next up, we have chicken tigela,
which is basically grilled
chicken, some corn,
some roasted veggies, and tomato,
and this is served with some spicy rice.
They've also given a bunch of veggies.
Nando's is really trying
to get our vitamins in.
But take a look at the tigela itself.
It's got a bed of rice underneath,
but on top there's some pulled chicken,
a lot of grilled onions,
and a lot of finely chopped capsicum.
Next up, you have the option
of a pulled-chicken wrap.
I mean, it looks like a wrap.
Or you can also get a pulled-chicken pita.
Damn, this looks like a doner kebab.
I guess the true test of whether Nando's
is putting a lot of effort into their food
is whether their wraps
and their pita taste good.
Let's go.
Miles better than any
other fast-food restaurant.
Alongside those, you can
get a tub of veggies.
So, next up is chicken skewers,
for a kebab-eating nation.
Good job, Nando's.
You get these along with some pita bread
and a couple of salsas.
You get a yogurt sauce and some salsa.
Next up, we have Portuguese
chicken and gravy,
and if you can't tell from my face,
I'm having a great time.
Ooh, boy!
Look at that.
It looks like there's tarka
on top, dude! Oh, my God!
What is a tarka, you ask?
Basically it's the best way
to finish off a curry here in India.
We take oil, heat it,
add some spices in there,
temper them, and then
pour them over our curry.
And our final meal-deal dish
is saucy chicken strips in spicy rice.
I'm not gonna lie,
this one looks like the most boring option
out of everything here.
Let's look at some of the
burgers and wraps from Nando's.
In the UK, we have a couple
of exclusive options.
Firstly, we have the Sunset burger.
If I had to hazard a guess as to why
this is called the Sunset burger,
it might be because you kind of get
a sunset yellow, orange, red effect going
with the cheese, the
chicken, and the chutney,
which looks very pretty.
I haven't had this before.
I wouldn't normally order it at Nando's,
but it's actually very, very good.
The bun is slightly different
to the regular burger buns that we get.
It's a little bit more spongy and pillowy,
and that chutney stuff is delicious.
Very sweet, little bit smoky.
Then we also have the fino pita.
I really love the packaging of this.
It's great for delivery.
You just tear straight through the middle,
not like that,
and then pop that off.
You have a nicely preserved upright pita.
Now, on a fino pita,
you get chicken thighs,
you get some salad, you get
perinaise, you get halloumi,
and I think there's also
some caramelized onions
in there as well.
I'll be honest. If I'm going to Nando's,
this is what I'm getting.
It's kind of got all my
favorite Nando's things
in one little package.
They took it off the
menu for the pandemic.
They've recently brought it back,
which I am thrilled about,
'cause I've missed it dearly.
The cheeky Nando's level's
off the charts right now.
We have a couple of exclusive burgers
and wrap flavors of our own,
starting with the chicken
Caesar salad wrap.
I kind of like that packaging.
Let's see how this tastes.
That is a messed-up way to eat a wrap.
Eat it from the top, not from
the side, please, Nikhil.
Wow.
Next up is the peri cheeseburger,
which also comes as a
wrap or in pita form.
Look how the juice is
dripping off this thing, man!
That's what I'm talking about.
This flavor has just taken India by storm
in the past few decades.
It's part of the trifecta of ingredients
that are red velvet, matcha, and peri-peri
that people just love to put
into every menu over here.
Peri-peri, if you don't know,
is a spice mix that was
discovered by Portuguese explorers
when they were settling/pillaging
south African countries, like
South Africa and Mozambique.
On the subject of
foreigners coming to a place
and taking things from it,
I would like to formally
apologize to India from the UK.
Feel free to come and take your stuff back
from the British Museum
whenever it's convenient.
I feel like most Indians
identify peri-peri
as the little packets of
peri-peri you get at McDonald's,
and you pour them into your fries
and shake them to get peri-peri fries.
I feel like when they come to Nando's,
they might find it not spicy enough.
If you don't eat meat, Nando's
is actually pretty good
for vegetarian and
vegan options in the UK.
First up, we have the Great Imitator wrap.
It doesn't look very appealing right now.
However, the Great
Imitator is Nando's version
of fake chicken.
I think it's made with pea protein,
and by all accounts, I've
heard it's pretty good.
Then we have the Beanie burger.
As the name would suggest,
it's a bean patty.
Also comes with, I believe,
an egg-free mayo, some salad as well.
Then we have a spiced chickpea burger.
It's kind of similar to
the Beanie burger, however,
once again, as the name would suggest,
the patty is predominantly
made of chickpeas.
This one actually mirrors the
Sunset burger a little more
because it's got the same bun
and also has some of
that red-pepper chutney.
And then finally we have
a portobello mushroom
and halloumi pita.
It's a pita bread with a big
portobello mushroom inside
as well as some salad, some halloumi,
and more of that red pepper chutney.
Pretty much every fast-food
restaurant here in India
serves vegetarian food,
because a huge percentage of
the country is vegetarian.
Having said that, Nando's actually had
quite a few non-vegetarian options,
which is very cool to see
in a restaurant like this.
So let's go off the list
of vegetarian food now,
starting with creamy cashew
paneer and spicy rice.
So, this is the same thing
as the creamy cashew chicken,
except they've replaced it
with chunks of cottage cheese,
and it just looks delicious.
Let's see if Nando's
has done paneer right.
It's really nice, and it's not as chewy.
It's soft. Soft paneer
at a fast-food chain.
Unheard of.
The next vegetarian dish
is called Something Exotic.
Ooh! It's a mystery.
Even they don't know what it could be.
And it is ...
What the heck?
I did not expect to see this.
It's watermelon and paneer.
You know, Nando's, watermelon and paneer,
you really are walking the line between
creativity and abomination.
No. Those are kind of weird together,
but I think overall this is a fun dish.
And they serve it along
with a three-bean salad.
The three beans are chickpea,
rajma, and some other one.
Let's taste.
Even this is flavorful. What's going on?
OK, now we're moving on
to a vegetarian version
of the cataplana.
They have tossed the same vegetables,
but this time along with
paneer and some chickpea.
I'll only taste the chickpea.
Very nice.
This is easily the best food
I've had on "Food Wars."
Hands
OK, next up we have a vegetarian version
of the espetada as well.
Look at this!
This is probably the best veg
skewer I've seen in my life.
It's just too beautiful, I can't eat it.
I must frame this in my home.
Also, they serve it with garlic bread,
because this isn't enough apparently.
The first one is a veg burger.
They serve it with coleslaw.
It's a run-of-the-mill frozen patty.
It's all right.
This is probably the
most underwhelming thing
on the menu so far.
And finally, they have a
mushroom and paneer burger.
Both of these options you can
get along with a wrap or pita.
They have put
a huge chunk of paneer in there.
Have you seen a paneer this big?
I didn't even know they made this s---.
Superb burger.
When there's good food in
this show, I'm so happy!
And that's not all.
There are more vegetarian options
from the meal-deal section.
Let's go from the top.
First off, we have veg sliders.
These ones have patties
instead of pulled chicken.
Next up, you can get a veg
tigela. This one has paneer.
So, same thing, it's a bed of rice,
some chopped veggies on top,
but with paneer as the protein.
It's served along with potato wedges.
Next up, we have paneer
skewers that you can get
along with either spiced
rice or with some pita bread.
Very similar to the skewers
we had with chicken,
and they seem to have
the same sauce as well.
They're served along with either
pita bread or spiced rice.
You can choose which option of side,
and you also get a salsa
as well as a yogurt dip.
I always feel like it's hard
to do skewers with paneer,
because it's such a delicate ingredient
that if you fry it too
much it gets too rubbery.
Oh, is that a piece of
pineapple there? Oh!
There's a lot of thought
put into these dishes.
Nando's is a class apart.
It's just a class apart!
And finally, we have a very
simple option at the end.
It's roasted veg and some grilled paneer.
I'd probably skip this one.
Next up, the UK exclusive starters.
First up, we've got
some sweet potato wedges
and garlic perinaise.
For some reason, they've also mixed in
a bunch of regular chips as well.
I don't know if that's normal,
because I'm traditionally
not going to order sweet potato fries.
If you've watched "Food
Wars" for a long time,
you will know my thoughts on sweet potato,
namely that they are bad.
It's just like someone
took a chip and went,
"How can we make this floppier?
I know!"
The garlic perinaise, however, very tasty.
Would recommend getting a side of this
next time you're in Nando's.
Also exclusive to the
UK are peri-peri nuts.
You can start your meal off
with a combination of, I think,
cashews, almonds, and
maybe macadamia nuts,
all coated in their
signature peri-peri spice.
I'm usually pretty good at this.
Let's find out.
In the UK, you can also
get fried halloumi sticks
and a dip of your choice.
However, unfortunately,
the restaurant forgot ours.
Here's what they're supposed to look like.
Neither of these are exclusive,
but in both countries,
you can also start with hummus and olives.
India has a variety of options,
starting with the cheesy fiesta fries.
Seems pretty straightforward,
but let's see if it is a fiesta.
Oh, my God. Bro, their
presentation is off the charts.
Look at this. Look at this.
Everybody marvel at the presentation.
OK, I will say
these have been in the cold for a while,
so they may not taste as
good as when they're fresh.
And I am right.
Next up, they have cheesy fiesta chicken.
Boom!
It's pulled chicken,
grilled onions, same cheese,
and I imagine there's fries underneath.
Next up, they have something called
the sweet potato and corn snack.
Whoa! Why is their food so beautiful?
There's corn, there's bits of red paprika,
some chopped parsley,
but also it's pieces
of thinly sliced lemon.
That's new.
Oh!
Are you supposed to eat that?
It's interesting.
I don't know if I'd serve
lemon pieces in my salad.
Next up, we have four-piece wings,
but these ones are spicy, tangy wings.
They look quite delicious.
I'm going to sprinkle some lemon on there.
I'm disproportionately jealous
of that little lemon wedge with the wings.
Why don't we have that? Very little touch.
Lovely bit of freshness to your wing.
Forget about it.
I have to be honest. Pretty bland.
Not tasting any spice,
not getting any tang.
These are the most underwhelming
things on the menu so far.
And now for something
I did not expect to see
on the Nando's menu at all,
we have a creamy cashew
paneer and chicken naan.
More like Naando's.
Am I right, guys?
Bro,
why is all their food looking like art
that I can hang up on my wall?
OK, so this naan has the chicken,
so this is the naan-veg naan. [laughs]
Let's go ahead and take a
bite, see how it tastes.
It's damn good.
The gravy on top is very
similar to a butter chicken.
It's got a lot of sweetness and richness.
You can tell there's cashew in it,
but they've also sprinkled
on a lot of green chili,
some coriander, and chopped onions,
so there is a nice kick of spice,
and they just drizzled
a lot of malai on top,
so it's creamy.
This is what it would be like
if India had to have a pizza.
Banging.
Also, they serve it with
something called perinaise dip.
Are you sure this is for this?
Let's just avoid.
It's just, like, a huge tub of mayonnaise,
but it's perinaise, apparently.
For those looking for a healthier option,
Nando's also offers salads.
There are two main options in the UK.
Firstly, we have this quinoa
and peri-tomato salad.
This actually looks pretty
good, I have to say.
It looks like kind of sun-dried tomatoes,
some lettuce, some dressing,
some of these little crunchy
crouton-cracker things,
and, of course, quinoa.
And our other salad option
is the delightfully named
rainbow bowl.
Now, the very colorful rainbow
bowl comes with some hummus,
some coleslaw, some tenderstem broccoli.
There's some grains down in the corner
and I think some shredded carrot as well.
I love tenderstem broccoli
and will fight to the death
for tenderstem broccoli.
By default, the salads come plain,
but you can also add chicken
breast, chicken thighs,
fake chicken, or Beanie
patties to any of them.
Here at Nando's India, we
have salad options of our own,
starting with the Mediterranean salad.
Ooh la la! Opa!
Is that something Mediterranean?
Next up, we have an Algarve salad.
Looks pretty much the
same, minus the olives,
plus some cashew nuts and a lot of
sun-dried chili or tomatoes.
Then we have a quinoa salad,
for those of you who are monsters
and can't eat rice like a normal person.
And finally, we have a Caesar salad,
and the Caesar salad
comes with a dressing.
Now, all of those salads
we ordered are vegetarian,
but you can optionally
get some chicken strips
if you need more protein in there.
Then we're on to the sides.
In the UK, you can get
quite a few exclusive sides
to go along with your peri-peri chips.
First up, we have rainbow slaw,
which is coleslaw filled with Skittles.
No, it's not. It's just coleslaw.
But kind of colorful.
We also have a mixed-leaf salad.
Little box of leaves.
Oh, there's some tomato and
cucumber in there as well.
This one is spiced grains
with butternut squash,
which actually sounds pretty good.
Some grains in there, I
think that's feta cheese,
some green beans, and butternut squash.
Next up, we have creamy mash potato.
It's mash potato.
You can also get a side of
just some long-stem broccoli.
This one looks a little
more sad than the one
that was on the salad, but still great.
I think there's some garlic
in there as well. Nice touch.
And then finally we can get macho peas.
Peas for macho men, just like me.
I wasn't really sure where to put these,
but there are a couple of extra things
which you can add on to
pretty much any order,
so I guess they kind of count as sides.
First up, you can just
buy a couple of pieces
of grilled halloumi from
a Nando's in the UK.
For those of you who don't
know, halloumi is a cheese
which I think is made with
sometimes a mixture of
sheep and goat's milk,
predominantly produced in Cyprus.
It's an interesting cheese.
When you bite into it,
it doesn't really give. It's
got a kind of rubbery texture.
I personally find it
very satisfying to eat,
as do a lot of British people.
I think we're responsible
for something like 80%
of the Cyprus halloumi
consumption in the world,
which is kind of wild.
But, yeah, it's pretty good.
It, like, squeaks on your
teeth when you eat it.
The other sorts of side options include
just one whole portobello mushroom.
This might have looked OK when it was hot.
You can also just get a single
plain tortilla from Nando's.
I guess the idea is that you could buy
maybe the halloumi, the mushroom,
and a couple of other bits and sauces
and create your own wrap
or own burrito situation.
Personally, I don't think
it's worth doing that.
Just buy a preassembled one.
Options for sides here
at an India Nando's,
you can get potato veggies.
I already showed -- veggies?
No, no, they're not veggies,
they're potato wedges.
Run-of-the-mill potato wedges.
You can also get some chargrilled veg.
In fact, they give you a lot.
You can also get a three-bean salad,
which looks really colorful
and has, like, a soupy
liquid that I want to try.
Lentil soup, you say? Nay.
I want three-bean-salad water.
Next up, we have a Portuguese salad.
Looks pretty straightforward.
I have no idea what makes this Portuguese.
Is it the olives?
Probably.
And finally, you can just
get a tub of feta cheese.
They gave me six cubes of feta cheese.
Yeah.
Cool.
Nando's actually has quite
a few dessert options
in the UK. If you're in-store,
many of the shops will have an option
for bottomless frozen yogurt.
So you can have that in
the flavors of vanilla,
strawberry, chocolate, or mango.
In-store and also on delivery, you can get
a few more options,
including a Naughty Nata.
This is Nando's take on a
Portuguese egg-custard tart,
aka pastel de nata.
I've probably butchered
the pronunciation of that.
If I take myself out to Nando's
and I'm feeling bougie,
I'll probably end my
meal with one of these,
'cause I love these things.
We can also get a salted caramel brownie.
Look at that. It's very pretty.
It's got little gold sprinkles on it.
I'm describing more foods as pretty.
Been the theme of today.
But they are kind of pretty.
Next, we have a Choc-A-Lot cake,
which is a slice of what looks like
a pretty good, gooey, kind
of indulgent chocolate cake.
Pretty moist.
And then we also have this
gooey caramel cheesecake.
This is actually really good.
I'm a cheesecake fan,
but this is a great
example of a cheesecake.
I had it for the first time, I think,
when we filmed the UK versus US Nando's.
Go watch it now.
Highly recommend.
We don't share any desserts with the UK,
but we have our own
desserts, starting with
an ice cream and hot chocolate,
but they don't deliver it,
so here's an image of it, I guess.
Looks pretty good. Looks nice.
Then we have a series of cakes,
starting with a chocolate cake.
It's parceled in a burger case,
which is kind of weird,
but, dude, look at this.
Thick, moist, fat cake.
I must taste for science.
Appropriately humid.
Next up, a red velvet cake.
What did I say?
The trifecta of ingredients.
I'm surprised there's no matcha milkshake
at the end of this.
They have to fit in red
velvet in every restaurant.
Peri-peri, red velvet, and matcha.
And finally, we have an
out-and-out cheesecake.
Honestly, all of these desserts are OK.
I'd probably skip the dessert here.
Last, but by no means least,
let's talk about the drinks.
If you go into a restaurant
of a Nando's in the UK,
you can get bottomless fizzy
drinks, including Coke,
diet Coke, Coke zero, Sprite, and Fanta.
Now, some people will ask
for a free glass of tap water
and then use that at the
fizzy-drink fountains
to help themselves to free fizzy drinks.
But I personally have
definitely never done that
and would not encourage
that kind of flagrantly
illegal behavior whatsoever.
On delivery, we do also have
a few exclusive drink options.
The first options are
these Bottlegreen cordials.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with cordials,
it's like a flavor concentrate.
So what you'll do is you'll
put a few splashes of this
into a glass, top it up with water,
and then you have a drink
that you can actually consume.
I kind of thought these
would come premixed,
so I was a little bit surprised
to see just bottles of the cordial itself.
But I guess you can make
yourself some squash at home.
This is roy-boss. Roy,
roy, roy-bows. I don't.
[whispers] I don't know
how to pronounce this.
Rooibos teas, which are
flavored with things
like lemon, peach, and berry.
And finally, we have
Gingerella, by Karma Drinks.
This is just a ginger ale.
We can also get bottomless
soda refills here in India,
but our bottled options
are fresh lime soda
and two iced-tea options.
I don't know if fresh lime
soda's a big thing abroad,
but over here in India
it is the No. 1 drink for
middle-class families.
When you go out with your family,
each person of the family
has a different order
for fresh lime soda. Some
like it with just salt,
some like it just sweet,
some like it with sweet and salt,
and some monsters like
it with no salt or sugar.
This is from a company called Brewhouse,
a tea-brewing company.
This is supposed to be
a mojito lemon iced tea.
It's nice.
And next, a peach iced tea.
Nando's also offers these
drinks called designer drinks,
which seem to be nonalcoholic
soft-drink cocktails.
It seems like they just
took 7Up and blended them
to form different flavors
with different colors.
But I'm curious to see if
they actually taste good.
Color, color, which color do you choose?
Let's try the virgin mojito.
Ah, tastes like a mojito
without the alcohol.
You can see they've gone the extra mile.
They've put in fresh lemon,
a lot of mint in there.
Next one is citra,
which I assume is a
mandarin/orange-flavored drink.
Oh, nice.
Very delicious. Super refreshing.
I thought this could be something
we could make fun of Nando's for,
but they've actually made some
delicious, refreshing drinks.
Ip dip do, the cat's got the flu,
the dog's got the
chickenpox, and so have you.
Portuguese lemonade.
Let's go.
What makes it Portuguese? I don't know.
Maybe it's olive oil. Let's see.
This is really yum.
So, it's not all sweet.
It has some sort of powder at the bottom.
Is it peri-peri powder?
I don't know, but it
tastes like chaat powder
that they put in a lot of
lemon sodas here in India,
and it's really yum.
Peach and elderflower.
They actually put a
slice of peach in there!
These are certified designer drinks.
Half a chicken, peri-peri chips,
and garlic bread at a UK Nando's
will cost you £13.10.
That same meal in India
will cost you rupees 800.69,
which at the time of filming this video
is equal to £9.85.
That's almost 25% cheaper of
a meal than the one in the UK.
OK, now while you Brits
might feel hard done by
because of these price differences,
I must say that this is
actually super expensive
for a single meal for a
single person here in India.
In fact, most people in this country
would find that almost aspirational.
You can get meals here
for close to 100 rupees.
That's less than a pound.
I would say that I can't
even consider this fast food.
It is the most expensive
restaurant we've tried here
on "Food Wars," but the food
was top class throughout,
so I guess it makes sense.
Now, Nando's does have some
slightly more affordable options
in the form of meal deals,
where you can get a single
meal for around 400 rupees,
which is equal to £4.50.
This doesn't seem like
a significant upgrade,
and it isn't.
In fact, the state that
we're filming this video
is Karnataka here in India,
and the daily wage is around 500 rupees.
So you would have to
literally work an entire day
to afford a single meal here at Nando's.
In fact, my first salary as an intern
was 10,000 rupees per month,
which is £125 per month.
And so if I ordered a "cheeky Nando's,"
it would literally be nearly one-tenth
of my entire monthly salary.
I'm not sure I'd consider Nando's
an affordable option in the UK,
and I'm not even really sure
I'd consider it fast food.
It sits somewhere in that
kind of fast-casual bracket,
combining elements of
fast-food restaurants
with elements of the more
traditional dining experience.
Some Brits don't really like Nando's
and might claim that
it's kind of overrated.
I personally love Nando's.
It's fast, it's consistent,
and I have a kind of
cultural attachment to it,
as I was kind of a teenager
when it really blew up
in popularity here in the UK.
I might be able to get
more value for money
at somewhere like a KFC, but to me,
it wouldn't hit the same.
Unfortunately, Nando's in the UK
doesn't disclose a full ingredients list.
Nando's in India also doesn't disclose
a full ingredient list.
So what do we know about the food?
Well, the FAQ pages on
our respective websites
do share some clues.
For example, in the UK,
Nando's says it uses Red
Tractor-assured chicken
from British farms. To
be Red Tractor-certified,
chickens must be raised
with certain benefits,
such as no cages and natural light.
The Indian FAQ page says
that all of Nando's chicken
in India is sourced from
India, and it's all cage-free.
They also say that all
the chickens are A grade.
Now, I don't know what this means,
because it's hard to keep up with
up-to-date poultry
practices here in India,
but one report from 2012
said that a top-grade chicken
must be "free of deformities that detract
from its appearance or that affect
the normal distribution of flesh.
Slight deformities,
such as slightly curved
or dented breast bones
and slightly curved backs
may be present."
Now, this sounds kind of vague,
but I do hope that Nando's
is following this practice
and only sourcing some A-grade chickens,
'cause that's what it tasted like.
Some A-grade chicken.
One other thing we can
glean from the FAQ page
is that the Great
Imitator wrap might not be
as plant-based as Nando's
seems to think it is.
This is because both the tortilla wrap
and also the glaze used on
the chicken contain shellac.
Shellac is a substance used
in food as a glazing agent,
but it's found in various other things,
such as nail polish,
fireworks, and sealants.
The twist is that it's
technically an animal product.
It's a resin secreted by lac beetles.
Female lac beetles will
secrete it onto trees
in the forests of India and Thailand,
where it's then harvested,
processed, and sold for use.
Do bugs count as animals
for the purpose of veganism?
I'm a meat eater, so I can't
really talk, but in my opinion,
I don't think a bug should
count. I think that's fine.
Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Cadbury chocolates
in the UK and in India.
This is "Food Wars."
Cadbury Dairy Milk in India
comes in ranges of four sizes.
No. 1 is Cadbury Dairy Milk minis.
It comes in this large packet
with 18 smaller pieces of 7 grams each.
Our smallest are these
bite-size 11-gram bars.
Then we have these 18-gram little bars.
A simple 24-grams tiny one.
Next up we have our multipack bars,
which weigh 33.5 grams.
The standard individual Dairy
Milk bar weighs 45 grams.
The duo bar, which comes in two halves
and weighs 54.4 grams.
Then a 55-grams maha pack.
Next up we have this 110-gram bar.
Family pack, 126 grams.
Then we move to a 180-gram bar.
We have this 360-gram bar.
The biggest size you'll find in the UK
is an 850-gram giant bar.
So, in India, Cadbury is really well known
for its gift boxes.
In fact, they've done so much
marketing over so many years
that it's become synonymous
with festivals like Diwali,
Dussehra, and even
Christmas and New Year's.
On their website right
now, you can get anything
from an anniversary tin
box to a Ramadan tin box.
And they come in several different sizes.
For starters, there's a
standard personalized gift box,
which contains six
Cadbury Dairy Milk bars,
three of which are Silk and
three of which are standard.
And that's the one we have right here.
In fact, they've put my face on it!
I mean, that's a whole lot of packaging
for normal bars of chocolate
you can just buy, I guess.
It even says "Food Wars"!
Oh, it says US versus India. Sorry, Harry.
Apart from this, you can also get
a larger personalized birthday gift box,
which will contain 450 grams of Silk bars,
three birthday whistles, a
large banner, a birthday hat.
So the next time you don't know what to do
for your birthday, just
order this to your house,
and you can have a party by yourself.
Now, we have some
gift-box items of our own,
but they usually come more in
the form of selection boxes.
These are most commonly
seen around Christmastime,
at which point Cadbury's will
release Heroes and Roses,
which are selection boxes
containing 600 grams
of individually wrapped chocolates.
It's a real tradition
in British households
to have a few of these lying around.
The other options include
Quality Street and Celebrations.
People tend to have their own favorites
when it comes to the selection boxes
and also the chocolates inside them.
I think generally Heroes would be
my preferred option over Roses.
I prefer the kind of more
mainstream chocolate bars
that you'll find, including
little Wispa bites,
which I think might be my favorites.
If you want a gift option
for all year round,
opt for a Milk Tray. These
have been around for decades.
I think my mum used to
be giving these to people
when she was growing up.
And for the run-up to Christmas,
you gotta get yourself an Advent calendar.
I don't think I'd normally
go for one of these.
These are a little bit
flimsy, quite narrow.
But still, you get a lot of joy
from opening a tiny bite
of chocolate every morning
in the run-up to Christmas.
Here are all the Cadbury products
that you'll find in India that
you will not find in the UK.
Here are all the Cadbury
products from the UK
that you won't find in India.
This is so much chocolate.
In terms of our classic
Dairy Milk flavors,
we have two exclusives.
No. 1, roast almond, and No. 2, crackle.
This used to be my favorite as a child,
but right now I really like this.
Delicious chunks of roast almond.
We have some exclusive Dairy
Milk flavors of our own.
Firstly, for the
health-conscious among us,
we have this 30% less sugar Dairy Milk.
I guess this could be helpful as well
if you find regular milk
chocolate too sweet,
which some people do,
but then I guess just opt for
some dark chocolate instead.
Next up we have Cadbury caramel.
It's a bar of Dairy Milk,
but inside each square there's
a little bit of caramel.
This is one of my favorite ones.
It does get a little bit sickly
if you eat too much of it
because of the amount of
sugar, but very tasty.
We have some Big Taste bars,
which are chunky versions of Dairy Milk,
starting with peanut caramel crisp.
And we also have a triple
choc sensation Big Taste bar,
which combines dark,
milk, and white chocolate
in one delicious bar.
These ones look really cool.
They've definitely put a bit more thought
into the design of the bars.
Tastes really good as well.
Next up, we've got Dairy
Milk with Crunchie bits.
Now, this is Crunchie with an
-ie, not crunchy with a -y.
Crunchie with an -ie is
actually a bar of chocolate
you can get here in the UK.
It's milk chocolate
with a honeycomb center.
Then we have a Dairy Milk Daim bar.
Daim is another chocolate bar
which Dairy Milk has
kind of collabed with.
I think it's a very thin,
brittle almond-caramel bar
with a little bit of
chocolate on the outside.
My granddad really used to like Daim.
Then we have this Marvellous Creations
jelly popping candy bar.
As the name suggests,
it's a bar of chocolate
which contains some popping candy
as well as I think jelly beans.
I've not tried this in a long time.
I want to see what the ratios are like
and also if I can really
feel the popping candy.
You can see a couple of bits of,
I assume, jelly beans
peeking out of the top.
The pattern is kind of odd.
Usually obviously you have squares.
Makes it nice and easy
to break apart and share.
I'm just gonna bite into it like a madman.
You really do get the popping
candy. My mouth is popping.
[popping]
It's actually not too bad.
You get little chewy sweet
bits in with your chocolate.
There's a lot going on,
but I don't hate it.
For vegans in the UK, Cadbury's
also has a plant-based bar.
I've never tried this, so I want to see
if I can taste the difference
between this and Dairy Milk.
I mean, it looks like chocolate.
Definitely does taste
of almond, which is OK,
'cause I quite like kind
of nut and chocolate
as a combination. If I went vegan,
I don't know if I'd be rushing
to the store to buy this.
It's OK. The texture's pretty good,
but the flavor just really isn't there.
Our last two exclusive Dairy Milk bars
are actually a mystery.
Two bars which contain
fillings of a mystery flavor.
You try and guess what the flavor is,
and then you can submit
your answer online.
Myself and the rest of the
crew have now got to try these
and give our best
guesses. Mystery bar one.
Oh, God. The last time
I threw stuff at you
it didn't go very well.
Leon: I've got it.
Harry: Ooh.
OK, it's fruity. Currently
we're thinking maybe rose.
I'm personally thinking apricot.
Struggling to agree here.
We can taste more. Swear I get fruit.
While we figure that one out,
we'll try mystery bar No. 2.
Now, this one smells aggressively fruity.
Catch, Leon.
I'm getting quite a lot of, like,
very artificial raspberry flavor.
I'd be fairly confident in
asserting that as raspberry.
It might be blueberry.
Plot twist, they've already
revealed the flavors.
We didn't know.
First one was rhubarb and
custard. Classic British dessert.
Didn't really get very close to that one.
Second was blue raspberry,
which we actually did kind of get.
I personally don't think I would buy
either of those again, though.
Charlie: Maybe the first one.
Harry: You don't mind it?
And now for our Silk range,
or, as Cadbury is trying
to rebrand it, the S range.
What is this? Some sort of new iPhone?
But whether you call it Silk
or S, I love these chocolates.
First off, we have the typical Silk.
Basically it's just Dairy
Milk but a lot silkier.
Then we have Dairy Milk Silk bubbly.
It's Dairy Milk Silk, but bubbly.
That's nice, light, airy.
Next, you have a Dairy
Milk Silk fruit and nut.
Then we have Dairy Milk Silk hazelnut.
Wow, there are some proper
large chunks of hazelnut.
The hazelnut itself,
the flavor of it really
lends to the chocolate,
and it doesn't taste as sweet.
Next up we have Dairy
Milk Silk roast almond.
We have Dairy Milk Silk mousse.
They've tried to recreate
the flavor of mousse,
and you can see that
it's a lot more fudgy,
the chocolate inside.
It's all right.
Oh, man, there's one
that I'm scared to try.
Dairy Milk Silk bubbly bubble gum.
Oh, no, I saw the color of it.
Oh, my God, why have they done this?
Growing up, we had a
bubble gum called Boomer,
which is now what we have all become.
That one bite was really not that bad.
It definitely tastes like bubble gum
and gave me that Boomer vibe.
That's as much as I can have of that.
Now, to cleanse the palate, Silk Oreo.
Mm!
That has a nice flavor to it.
I think this is my
favorite out of the lot.
We also have another variation of Oreo.
It's red velvet Oreo.
If you've watched previous
episodes of "Food Wars,"
you'll remember that
one of the ingredients
that has taken India by
storm in the past few decades
is red velvet.
And I have tasted this before,
and I actually think it's really good.
But it is overkill.
It's literally Dairy Milk
Silk, the Oreo white cream,
and chunks of Oreo that have
been turned into red velvet.
Do you have a treadmill?
Finally, we have Dairy
Milk Silk heart blush.
I imagine you give this to your loved one.
It says "pull" over here,
and I'm pretty excited to pull this.
"Never gonna give you up.
Never gonna let you down."
I can't believe I've been
Rickrolled in my own video!
At the back, there is a very
elaborate-looking tear tab,
so I'm just gonna ... ah!
Not very easy to -- wait, what?
I'd probably break up
with whoever gave me this
at this point. This is frustrating.
It's more packaging.
All right.
More packaging.
This is honestly a very wasteful way
to tell somebody you like them.
There you go. It's some pink chocolate.
Oh, my God, I swear to God,
if it's the same as the
bubble gum, I'm gonna cry.
It's not bubble gum, so.
This is actually quite a fun
experience, I'm not gonna lie.
Now, we don't have Silk bars,
but we do have something called Darkmilk.
Cadbury's has kind of invented this hybrid
milk and dark chocolate
for someone whose tastes
lie somewhere between those two.
Here is the Darkmilk.
Darkmilk also comes in variations
including a salted-caramel
flavor and a hazelnut flavor.
I feel like they've tried to
market these a little bit more
at adults, maybe, as opposed to kids.
The packaging kind of gives
a slightly more sophisticated
vibe. Sexy, if you will.
At the other end of
the scale, we have some
even sweeter options than
classic milk chocolate.
Firstly, we have Caramilk,
which is golden caramel chocolate.
This one I have not tried.
I'm kind of intrigued.
I'm going to have a bite.
I worry it's going to be far too sweet.
Wow, that's very sweet.
You do get notes of caramel,
but I really don't think I could eat
more than a couple of bites of that.
And, of course, we also
just have white chocolate.
As I've said, I'm not really
a big fan of white chocolate,
and I don't think I'm alone in that,
because this basically wasn't available
in any of the big
supermarkets that I looked in.
The shop we were able to track
it down in was Poundland,
which is a shop in the UK
where everything costs a pound.
I know it sounds ridiculous
to an American audience,
but that is what it's called.
So, you can find Cadbury
Bournville dark chocolate
in both the UK and in India,
but there's a slight difference.
In the UK, the packaging
is bright red, ew,
and over here we have different flavors,
50% dark chocolate and 70% dark chocolate.
I have over the years grown
to like dark chocolate.
I was never a fan of it growing up.
But 70% dark chocolate? I don't know.
Oh!
You know, it's not as bitter
as I expected. Very creamy.
Also, the cocoa is 100%
sustainably sourced.
Next up, we have a fruit and nut.
It's got a peanut in there.
It doesn't taste as heavy
as the other chocolates
I've had so far, and I
really appreciate this.
Am I growing old? Is
that what's happening?
And the final flavor is cranberry,
which I've been the most excited about.
I don't think I've had any chocolate bars
that have had cranberry in them,
but obviously cranberry and dark chocolate
sounds like an amazing combination.
That is so good! The
tartness of the cranberry
and, like, the slight sugariness
really complements the dark chocolate.
There's the crunch of roasted
almond. This is a winner.
Real nice. I like this
range of Bournvilles.
Feels like a healthier guilty pleasure.
We also have some Bournville products
you'll find in the UK that
you won't find in India.
Firstly, we have Bournville old Jamaica.
The "old Jamaica" refers
to rum and raisin flavors
added to the dark chocolate.
And we also have an orange Bournville.
I personally don't love dark chocolate,
and I especially do
not love dark chocolate
combined with fruit,
so I'm respectfully not
going to try any of these.
If you're wondering where the
name Bournville comes from,
it's actually a village that was created
by the Cadbury family for workers
who worked in their
factory near Birmingham.
Bournville still exists today,
so you can go and visit it.
It's home to Cadbury
World, which is a kind of
Cadbury museum
interactive-experience thing,
and apparently it's a
really nice place to live.
And now it's time for all of the remaining
Indian Cadbury products,
starting with Cadbury Fuse.
Their tagline for this is, "A
delicious chocolaty feast."
Like, some sort of chocolaty
mousse in the middle
surrounded by caramel,
and then the outer layer of
chocolate has peanuts in it.
So I can imagine this
being a proper feast.
Kind of nice.
I think I could eat this
much of one chocolate,
but the fact that I'm eating
so many varieties of chocolate
one after the other is really
doing something to my brain!
Like, why are we doing this?
No, like, what is this? Why
are we tasting all of this?
What is the point of this show?
Next in line, we have
the Cadbury Crispello.
I want to be on the team that gets to name
all of these chocolates.
Seems like you can just
get away with anything.
It's clearly filled
with some rice crispies
and things that are crispies.
Hey, this one is actually really yum.
Next up,
Cadbury 5 Star 3D.
If you don't know what 5
Star is, it's basically
the chocolate that made
caramel cool in India.
It's been around for decades,
and actually, fun fact,
it's my mom's favorite chocolate.
Now they've upgraded to 5 Star 3D.
What's the difference between
this and any other 5 Star?
It has nuts.
I will say, having eaten the
past three chocolates in a row,
I'm starting to realize
they're kind of the same thing.
It's decent. I prefer the original 5 Star.
That one sparks nostalgia.
This one just feels too modern.
Next up, we have a Perk.
So, Perk is another chocolate
that's been around in India
for ages now, and it's gone
through a lot of evolutions,
like every other chocolate has.
Now they sell Perk in a double pack.
It says you can "rip it, share it."
Oh!
Next up, some gemstones.
That's right, the UK didn't
give us our gemstones back,
but they definitely gave us Gems.
Yeah, I mean, fair enough. Sorry, guys.
So, they're M&M's without
the M&M branding on top.
What I used to do as a kid,
you would get a small packet of Gems,
and I would suck on each gem
until the color would come off
and it would be a white gem.
And then I'd put all the
white ones in my mouth
and bite them like one big chocolate.
I was weird, and I had no friends.
Cadbury Temptations rum and raisin. Rum?
And, uh, Cad, Cadbury, Cadbrury -- whoo!
Cadbury Temptations almond treat.
It smells like rum.
Whoa, I did not expect that
flavor to be so strong.
Can they sell this to children?
It kind of tastes like
a Christmas rum cake.
Yeah, I don't mind it. I
think this could be a great
Christmas sort of
chocolate to have around.
Next up is my favorite
childhood chocolate, Nutties.
I freaking love Nutties,
and my favorite part about Nutties
is that the branding
has not really changed
for, like, decades now.
What this chocolate is, is
basically Cadbury chocolate
coated over a cashew nut
that's covered in nougat.
Oh, my God, that is so good.
Then we have a load more
Cadbury exclusives in the UK,
and we'll start with the bars.
We'll start with what is
technically a Cadbury product
but initially was not.
This is the Fry's chocolate cream bar.
It's a dark-chocolate bar
with a creamy, smooth fondant center.
A fun factor is that the
Frys were a Quaker family
who were the first ones to
actually commercially produce
chocolate bars in the UK.
Before the Frys came along,
drinking chocolate was kind
of the only way to consume it.
Fry's also makes a peppermint cream bar
as well as Turkish delight.
I will say, this is not the
best Turkish delight out there.
If you want Turkish delight,
go to a grocery store
that sells Turkish food,
get some classic stuff,
whereas this is a kind of
slightly cheapy Turkish delight
encased in chocolate.
Next up, we have Boost bars.
These are chocolate bars
filled with caramel and biscuit pieces.
When Boost was first launched,
I think they were kind of
marketed as almost an energy bar.
They had loads of sugar
and glucose in them,
although I think they have now
recently dropped that down,
and it's just in line more
with a standard chocolate bar.
Then we're on to Chomps.
I personally love a Chomp.
These were also a little bit hard to find.
I think we had to go to
Poundland for these ones as well,
but they used to cost, like, 10p
from your local news agents.
It's just a chocolate bar
with toffee/caramel inside.
Simple but effective.
Then we have Crunchie bars,
which are chocolate bars
with a large honeycomb center.
Personally, don't love Crunchie bars.
I don't love the texture of the honeycomb,
and they're very, very sweet.
What I do love, however, is a Curly Wurly.
These are brilliantly named.
They come in these little
individual bars, like this.
They look a bit weird.
It's kind of a web of
chocolate and caramel.
I used to have braces as a kid,
and I really missed toffee and
caramel while I had them on.
Moving on, we have a Double Decker bar.
A nod to the British double-decker buses,
this is a two-layered chocolate
bar with a nougat layer
as well as a kind of
crunchy-pieces-in-caramel layer.
I like these.
Next up, we have Fudge bars.
Got these little bite-sized
ones today. I like these.
The guys seem to disagree with me,
but I think these are good.
I will opt for these in a Heroes box.
It's just a bar of fudge
covered with chocolate.
Then we move on to the Picnic bar.
It's a chocolate bar that
contains, I think, caramel,
some rice-crispy kind of pieces,
as well as some raisins and peanuts.
Now, while India has a 5 Star bar,
in the UK, we just have a Starbar.
I don't think I've ever
had one of these before.
Apparently it's milk chocolate
with caramel and peanut.
Let's give it a try.
That might get added to
my rotation, you know?
That's pretty good.
Next up, we have the Twirl.
These are, like, ribboned chocolate bars
which are then kind of
cased within more chocolate.
It leads to quite an interesting texture
and quite a nice taste.
The only issue with Twirls
is that they do crumble
and kind of go everywhere.
You can also get Twirls
in an orange flavor.
Then we're on to Wispa bars. Shh.
I don't really know how they make these,
because it's milk chocolate,
but it's, like, aerated.
There's kind of little holes
all the way through it.
We put a man on the moon, and
we aerated a chocolate bar.
The result is a really
nice texture, actually.
It sort of melts in your
mouth when you eat it.
I've some American colleagues in the US.
Last time I visited,
this was the one thing they
asked me to bring over.
You can also get Wispa gold bars.
These are the same as regular Wispas,
but they have a layer of
caramel running along the top.
And the last-but-by-no-means-least
bar is the Freddo.
It's basically just a tiny
piece of solid milk chocolate
in the shape of Freddo the frog.
But for people of a certain
generation, namely mine,
they're also a surprising representation
of economic inflation.
To put on my angry-old-man
hat for a second,
when I was a youngin', these were 10p,
and then around 2005, prices
started to gradually creep up.
Before we knew it, prices were as high
as 30p for a Freddo.
These outrageous prices
actually led to public outcry,
so much so that they backed down,
and I think nowadays they're around 25p.
The Bank of England says
that it should have been
around 17 or 18p by now,
whereas we are getting charged 25,
so Cadbury's, give us
some cheap Freddos again.
Economic rant is now over.
You can also get Freddos
in a caramel flavor.
The last thing to add
to the chocolate bars
is that you can get
pretty much all of them
in the form of these share bags.
They basically just condense
them into bite-size pieces
and put them in a bag that
you can open and reseal.
Next up, we have Dairy Milk Bites.
There are two flavors
that we have right now,
hazelnut and almond.
They look pretty similar to
the Silk of these flavors,
so I imagine these are just
smaller bite-sized versions.
Next up, Lickables.
Why have they done this?
Thoughts on this? This is
clearly for small children.
Somebody want to help me? I
have no idea how to open this.
This feels like one of those puzzles.
Oh!
[crew clapping]
The lower half of it was a chocolate,
and the rest of it had this toy.
Now to the chocolate.
There's a QR code, because
most children have phones
that they can scan this with.
Oh!
Looks like goopy Cadbury chocolate
with chunks of Oreo,
and you just gotta lick it.
This is just weird, Cadbury.
OK, next up we have Cadbury Chocobakes
choc-filled cookies.
In case you didn't think
this contained chocolate,
they reminded you eight
times in the branding.
The packaging and the design
feels a lot more premium.
I feel like there's good
value for money here,
because it was filled to the literal brim.
Now we're going to go to this side.
We have Oreo dipped in Cadbury, damn.
I'm really enjoying this whole
Oreo-Cadbury marriage over here.
Now we have an Oreo biscuit
coated in Cadbury chocolate.
The Oreo biscuits are
just kind of overpowering,
so it's all right.
Next up we have this tin
can of rich dry fruits.
Again, in the Cadbury Celebrations line.
In India, a common gifting culture
is to give a box of dry fruits and nuts,
and so Cadbury's adapting
really well to that.
All right, so the next thing
is something very different.
This is actually Bournvita,
or Cadbury Bournvita,
and this is a drinking chocolate.
We drink a lot of milk here in India,
and as kids, everybody was addicted
to one of many different
drinking chocolates.
Horlicks, Complan, I'm a Milo guy myself.
There was Boost, and
then obviously Bournvita.
I think most people were
not Bournvita people.
This is Cadbury's range of choco melts,
and it's a small disk of
chocolate that's used for baking.
And finally, the last
three packets are toffees
that Cadbury sells in bulk.
This one is 5 Star bites.
It's similar to the Dairy Milk minis.
For all my Indian fans
of 5 Star out there,
comment and let me know whether you're
more of a Ramesh guy or Suresh guy.
These are packs of toffees.
Eclairs, to be specific.
This one is chocolate-flavored,
and this one is coffee-flavored.
Another quirky thing about India
is sometimes when you
go to the local stores
and you pay in cash and
they have to give you change
but they don't have any,
they'll just give you
one of these chocolates.
And you can't really argue
it, you just grab it and go.
I think it's very cute, actually.
It's a very endearing thing about India.
But remember, if you're gonna
take a chocolate from a store,
screw all this. Take Melody.
Melody is the best chocolate, all right?
In the UK, Cadbury's offers
a lot of seasonal products.
Now, we're recording this
episode in late October,
so unfortunately we can't get
some of the most famous ones.
What I'm of course referring to here
are Cadbury Creme Eggs
and Cadbury Mini Eggs.
In the UK, these are only available
in the run-up to the Easter holidays,
but while they are available,
they're wildly popular.
Well, I will say, I don't like Creme Eggs.
I take stick for this.
I think they're gross.
The fondant in the middle is grim.
You have to kind of, like, tongue it out.
It's just really bizarre.
Mini Eggs, however, are delicious.
I don't know what they're
putting in the shells
of those things, but,
God, they're amazing.
While we can't get the
Easter exclusives right now,
what we do have are Halloween
and Christmas options.
For Halloween, I was able
to find these Goo Heads.
I think these are kind
of the Halloween version
of Creme Eggs, so I'm going
to crack one open and see.
That does look exactly
the same as a Creme Egg,
even down to the patterning
that's printed on the egg.
I mean, yeah, that's pretty
much just a Creme Egg.
I just don't like them.
Now, for Christmas exclusives,
I found these Cadbury Puds.
These are Dairy Milk chocolate
balls with a truffle center,
hazelnut pieces, and rice crisps.
They sound pretty good.
We also found Cadbury Mini Snow Balls,
which are milk chocolate
in a crisp sugar shell.
They might hurt a little bit more
than a normal snowball fight
if you have one of these
thrown at your head.
And, of course, you can get a Dairy Milk
Advent calendar for Christmas.
It looks like some kind of mud monster.
Moving away from seasonal
items, we have Cadbury Eclairs.
Cadbury Eclairs are quite
tough pieces of toffee
with some chocolate in the center.
They're a pretty good jaw workout,
but I do quite like these.
And another iconic
Cadbury item is Buttons.
These are bags of disks
of Dairy Milk chocolate.
Real classic. These have
been around for years.
From there, we're moving on
to Cadbury's biscuit options,
possibly the most iconic
of which are Fingers.
These are thin sticks of sweet biscuit
covered in Dairy Milk chocolate.
They're very tasty,
they're pretty moreish,
and they come in these kind
of iconic sleeve-tray things.
I know with Joe we have a caffeine meter,
but if I had a sugar meter, pew!
We are blasting off right now. Whoo!
We also have some other flavor
options, including mint,
orange, Bournville dark,
and, finally, white.
Roundies are circular
layered wafer biscuits
covered in Dairy Milk chocolate.
If you're a fan of wafers,
you can also get Timeout Wafer bars.
Again, it's chocolate wafers
layered and surrounded by chocolate,
but this time in more of a bar
form than a circular biscuit.
The next Cadbury biscuits
option is Animals.
"Freddo has hopped into the
jungle to join his friends."
These are little animal-shaped biscuits
which on one side are
covered with chocolate.
I don't think I've eaten
one of these as an adult,
but they were an excellent
lunch-box addition
when I was a little kid.
I'd also be remiss not
to talk about Mini Rolls.
These are an iconic British snack.
What it is, is a chocolate sponge
with this kind of cream
swirl in the middle,
surrounded by milk chocolate.
I'm not sure why the Mini
Roll is currently saying,
"I'm rich and famous," but
good for the Mini Roll.
These are great.
Finally, Cadbury's offers
some baked options,
which you might find in the bakery section
of your local supermarket.
These can include things
like doughnuts and muffins,
but the ones I was able to
find today were flapjack bites.
In the UK, when we say flapjacks,
we don't mean pancakes,
which I think Americans can say sometimes.
Flapjacks over here are kind
of like oats held together
with honey, golden syrup,
and some other stuff.
And these mini cookies.
Here's everything in a bar
of Dairy Milk chocolate in the UK.
Here's everything you'll find in a bar
of Dairy Milk chocolate here in India.
So, the list of ingredients
is pretty much the same
in the UK and in India.
But the UK uses palm and shea fats,
which is not specifically
listed here in India.
India goes into a little bit
more detail on the flavorings
used in the chocolate,
listing natural vanillin
as well as artificial ethyl vanillin.
As the name suggests,
this is the main component
of vanilla-bean extract.
Some kind of vanillin is likely
present in the UK chocolate,
it's just contained within
the flavorings on the list.
But how much chocolate
are you actually getting
in your chocolate?
The Food Safety and
Standards Authority of India
has some minimum requirements
for what milk chocolate should contain.
The rules are 25% total fat, 2% milk fat,
2.5% cocoa solids, and 10.5% milk solids.
We have equivalent rules here in the UK.
The Cocoa and Chocolate
Products Regulations of 2003
set the minimums for milk
chocolate at 25% total fat,
5% milk fat, 20% dry cocoa solids,
2.5% dry nonfat cocoa solids,
and 20% dry milk solids.
Cadbury in the UK says
its chocolate contains
23% milk solids
and meets the EU minimum
of 20% for cocoa solids.
India's Cadbury packaging says it contains
over 22% milk solids.
So thank you, Cadbury,
for not being chindi.
It is interesting that Indian
rules do not have a minimum
for dry fat-free cocoa
solids in milk chocolate.
The dark chocolates, however,
have a minimum, and it's 14%.
"Dry cocoa solids" tends
to refer to cocoa powder,
which is one of the purest forms of cocoa.
Having more cocoa solids
therefore gives the end product
a stronger chocolate taste.
100 grams of Dairy Milk in
the UK contains the following.
100 grams of Dairy Milk in India contains:
The calories are actually identical.
The least-healthy bar in the UK
is the Big Taste toffee whole nut bar.
One of these contains 560
calories per 100 grams,
a slight increase on Dairy Milk.
But what is the least-healthy
chocolate bar here in India?
It's the Dairy Milk Silk hazelnut.
100 grams of this contains 571 calories,
which is more than any bar in the UK.
I guess it's a win? I'm
counting it as a win.
Nikhil: From calorie
down to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Lay's chips in
the US and in India.
This is "Food Wars."
Here are all the Lay's
chips you'll find in India
that you won't find in the US.
And here are all the Lay's chips in the US
you can't find in India.
Oh, my good God. Yeah!
To begin things, I'm
going to go with the one
I hate the most, Spanish tomato tango.
Yeah, I just never
really liked this flavor.
It's just too heavy on the tomato side.
No. Oh, man, that aftertaste is horrible.
I have nothing nice to
say about this flavor.
Also, just to note, our
standard Lay's chips
come in the ridge style.
We do also sell the flat style,
but that's more of a
special variety of Lay's.
Next, it's West Indies
hot and sweet chili,
formerly Caribbean hot and sweet chili.
That's what I'm talking about.
Get out of here!
And now for the maharaja of Indian Lay's,
magic masala.
If you haven't heard of this,
you must be living under a rock,
because this is the
little emperor of chips.
Commonly known as blue Lay's.
Look at this chip, dude!
Oh, my God.
It's already so spicy.
The reason this chip has
become so popular in India
is because they have
actually managed to capture
the masala of India so well.
And masala, if you're wondering,
is, like, ground-up spices
that are added to every
single dish we eat here.
This is truly magic.
I want to know what they're like.
Joe got himself something.
Oh, man.
And the chip bags in India
are, like, much harder to open.
Oh, man! You guys got
them locked up tight.
Got a rip! OK.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, these are good!
Not too spicy.
Great flavor.
We have so many flavors.
I couldn't get them all for this shoot.
I mean, I'll just start right here.
Barbecue. This is the classic chip.
I think this is more popular
than the classic, to be honest.
The US has, I would say,
at least 10 different variations
of barbecue, possibly more.
So to have just, like,
standard barbecue is
pretty bold move by Lay's.
Salt and vinegar.
[dreamy harp tune]
Love salt and vinegar so much.
I love it so much.
Top chip. Top chip right here.
Love salt and vinegar.
Cheddar and sour cream.
Ha ha ha, limón.
Another favorite. Oh, man.
It seems like lime-flavored
chips would be weird,
or citrusy chips, but ...
so good.
And these are, like, really limey.
All the superfans watching
know I do not like pickles.
No.
Let's kick it up a notch.
Flamin' Hot dill pickle.
And the Flamin' Hot, that font,
that implies that's
Flamin' Hot Cheetos, right?
Mm. Better.
Still not that good.
Last in this group is a chili limón.
Yeah.
These are coming home with me.
Other flavors in this category
that I couldn't get at
the time of filming,
cheddar jalapeño and sweet
Southern heat barbecue.
I was totally able to buy them online.
I get a thing in the mail two days ago
saying the post office
is holding them ransom
and wants 5 more dollars for
postage for me to pick it up.
Not happening.
I will not be intimidated by
the United States post office.
You keep the chips, all right?
Also what I couldn't get
at the time of filming
was honey barbecue,
Chesapeake Bay crab spice,
adobadas, which is a different spicy chip
which is actually very good.
I was bummed I couldn't get those.
And the Doritos Cool Ranch
Lay's, unfortunately.
Let's now talk about two exclusive flavors
that are in both countries,
but slightly different.
We have the sizzlin' hot Lay's
and the American-style cream and onion.
It was previously known as
American sour cream and onion.
It's great. No fuss.
One of my favorite flavors.
It's been there for, like,
over two decades, I feel,
in India, and there's a reason for that.
Ours is just regular sour cream and onion.
And I also got American-style
sour cream and onion
from India.
And then,
one after the other.
The flavor on these are much stronger.
And it even says, "Now with more flavor."
This is more flavor?
I gotta say, I like
these India ones better.
Up next, we have sizzlin' hot.
This is a flavor I've actually never had.
I'm very excited to see how it stacks
compared to magic masala,
which is already pretty spicy.
Whoa.
Yo, look at this chip.
It's literally red.
Not really -- oh.
Nice.
It's not as much a direct
heat as the magic masala.
Hey, this is a nice flavor.
In the US, we have Flamin' Hot flavor.
Now, let me explain.
This is Flamin' Hot kettle chips.
Couldn't get the regular Flamin' Hot.
We'll get into kettle chips later.
It's, like, regular spice.
It has a heat to it
without being too specific.
I think they use these
red chilies right here.
It packs a nice punch
without being too
overwhelming with the flavor.
They're, like, the perfect amount of heat
without getting too overwhelming, so.
OK, so we don't only
have ridge-style chips,
we also have some flat ones.
In fact, they're called wafer style,
which I think is pretty much
your classic style of Lay's.
The first flavor is salt with pepper.
Not salt and pepper.
Don't you dare say that.
It's very nice. I should
buy these more often.
I've never tried these
before. Very good job.
OK, on to the next wafer-style chip.
We have sun-dried chili.
Mm! I love sun-dried anything.
Beam that sun ray onto any
vegetable. I will eat it.
Oh, damn.
This is really good.
They smashed it with this one.
Got a proper kick as well.
Ooh!
It's really yum.
And one of the most beautiful
sights you'll see in India
is people sun-drying their
own chilies on their roofs,
porches, wherever.
Biryanis, curries, they
all use sun-dried chili.
And this chip's packet really
has nailed this flavor.
Maybe my favorite, kettle cooked.
We already saw the
Flamin' Hot kettle cooked.
These are thicker chip.
They transport a lot better, obviously.
There are not as many broken.
It's got more of, like, a potato
taste to it, a potato snap.
It's like ...
I love kettle chips.
Sea salt, cracked pepper.
These are so good.
Mm. Yeah!
It's like ...
booyah!
[grunts]
Sea salt and vinegar.
This ain't your pond salt.
This ain't your lake salt.
This certainly is not your fjord salt.
Why is salt and vinegar so good?
Attention, everyone,
my favorite kettle chip is
about to be eaten by me.
The jalapeño kettle chips.
I'm not going to talk about Miss Vickie's
because this isn't a Miss Vickie's video.
And I hate to say it.
These might be better.
They've got the jalapeño flavor in there.
It's not too spicy,
so you can really chow down on these.
Moving on, unfortunately,
to something that I kind of can't stand,
are baked. Wah-wah.
You can get them in original
and you can get them in barbecue.
Like eating cardboard.
Lay's has something called
the Better for You series.
So we have these, and then
lightly salted barbecue,
lightly salted wavy.
I mean, I want the salt,
but, like, how much ... ?
This is what paper tastes like.
We got simply sea salt thick cut.
And you can also get the
simply barbecue thick cut.
They have something called
layers, which are these guys.
Bite-size layers, crispy
layers, tasty layers.
You can get them in three
cheese, sour cream and onion.
I've never seen these
before in my entire life.
Oh, the bag stinks!
Oh, these are really bad.
These are terrible.
Whoa, these are real chemically tasting.
Oh, my God, these taste
like they were poisoned.
And now for our next
range of exclusive chips,
we have Lay's Maxx.
That's Maxx with two X's.
Why the two X's? That's like
saying it's more better.
I have not seen or tasted these before.
Starting with macho chili flavor.
It is kind of ridged, but
I would say it's more wavy.
I wouldn't say it's super spicy.
I kind of like that this one doesn't leave
that burning sensation in your throat.
It's really nice.
Yeah. I don't know about the branding,
but I really like this flavor.
Next flavor, peppery cheddar.
Whoa. All sorts of stuff happening here.
There's, like, some mint to it.
Oh, you know what this tastes like?
This tastes like malai tikka,
like chicken malai tikka
dipped in pudina chutney.
This is very unique.
Our next flavor is sizzling barbecue.
Oh, the reason this is called Lay's Maxx,
it's because it has
max crunch, max flavor,
and max taste.
And I can wholeheartedly say
both of these have delivered.
Mm. It even smells
strongly of barbecue, so.
These work. They're great.
More fun chip styles.
I think we can call these the India style,
but we also call them the wavy style.
They are wavy, hence the name.
And you can get them in
original, reduced fat,
honey barbecue, ranch,
and you can also get
them in salt and pepper,
lightly salted,
fat, low fat, if I
didn't say that already.
The waves are, like, wider.
You guys have, like,
really condensed waves.
Lay's apparently wanted to
answer the age-old question,
how can we copy something popular
and make it much, much worse?
And Stax were invented.
You guys know what Pringles are, right?
Of course you do. Well.
[chip pieces rattling] Hear that?
"We'll put them in a tube.
They won't break as easily."
Right? [chip pieces rattling]
Holy f---.
Look at this.
Then what was the point of
putting it in this tube?
I hate this so much.
But to really prove my point,
yo, dog, look what I got.
By the way, paper too. Excellent idea,
Dave Pringle, whatever your name is.
F--- Stax.
And now to our final set of exclusives,
the gourmet collection.
I've had a lot of gourmet food in my life,
and I've very rarely been
actually impressed with the food.
Vintage cheese and paprika!
Vintage cheese and paprika.
Oh.
If I had tasted this chip
without any of the fancy packaging,
I don't think gourmet is the first word
that would come to my head.
Thai sweet chili gourmet.
This literally tastes like
the West Indies hot and chili,
but on a flat chip.
So gourmet is just packaging.
That's what we've learned
from this experiment
with these two chips.
Skippable.
In addition to that, we
also have Lay's Poppables.
Poppables come in sea salt and vinegar --
oh, Julius Pringle! That
was his name. Not Dave.
They also have Poppables
sea salt and vinegar,
Poppables sea salt,
Poppable white cheddar,
and Poppable honey barbecue.
OK, I don't want to eat all these.
What's the cereal that looks like this?
Is it Chex?
If you got these on accident, eat them,
but I wouldn't reach for these
over regular potato chips.
Here in India, our Lay's chips
packets come in five sizes.
There's 30 grams, 50 grams,
73 grams, 104 grams,
and 174 grams.
The big boy. The party pack.
I feel like I could eat
this whole thing on my own,
to be honest.
In the US, our Lay's chips
come in six variety of sizes.
All the way down here, got a 28-gram bag,
which comes in the multipack.
Next up, 74.4-gram bag.
In the middle here, there's
also an elusive 78-gram bag.
Look, I saw it on Target.com
and Walmart.com. It exists.
It just wasn't available
anywhere in Southern California.
I looked, OK?
One step up, we have what I think
is the classic grocery-store bag,
226 gram, aka the 8-ounce bag.
You've seen it a million
times. This is the one.
Right next to that one
is the family-sized bag,
which I also couldn't get ahold of.
297.6-gram bag.
I couldn't find it because
the American family is dead.
But what is alive and well is,
of course, our biggest size,
the party size, 368 grams.
All you family-less partyers,
Lay's has you covered.
That means that the biggest bag in the US
is this much larger than
the biggest bag in India.
But wait, there's more,
or less, depending on
the packet that you get,
because according to Amazon,
the weights of these
different packets might vary.
So they're given a weight range.
The biggest weight difference
is in our largest pack
of 174 to 190 grams, which
is a difference of 16 grams.
So let's see how much
we get in one packet.
Ooh!
175 grams, one gram extra
from what is advertised,
which is, I'll take it.
So let me show you what 16
grams of chips looks like,
so you can see what you're
potentially missing out on.
It doesn't seem like a
lot, but I think that's
quite a substantial amount of
chips you're missing out on.
To be fair, they did write
174 grams only on the pack.
In the US, our flavor bags weigh less
than the original-flavor bag.
Take this barbecue-flavored Lay's bag.
It weighs 7.75 ounces, or 7 ¾ ounces.
Yuelei, can we get in there?
You see that? Thank you.
Compared to the 8 ounce you
get with the original bag.
OK. Same price, less product.
Now, Harry did research on that episode,
so take it away, Harry.
What? No, do your own research.
According to Harry's research
from the last Lay's episode,
back in 2014, PepsiCo claimed
the reason that there is
a slightly higher price per
ounce for flavored chips
is the added seasoning.
So then, Lay's,
can you explain to me why
this lightly salted bag
gives you fewer chips
than the original bag?
It's more money but less salt, eh, Lay's?
Check it out.
The lightly salted, so
less salted than this,
also 7 ¾.
While we're exposing potential Lay's lies,
this 28-gram bag in the US
supposedly contains 15 chips,
according to Lay's website.
Let's see how accurate this is.
And I'm going to count all the
chips in this 30-gram packet
to see how many we have.
I mean, it doesn't contain one whole chip.
One.
12, 13.
I mean, if we're doing it
by chip-related piles ...
six, 12, eight?
Close to 18 chips per bag.
Huh. All right, I'll concede.
Cool, so that's 24 chips.
I would say, realistically,
this is, like, 20 chips
that have been broken
into many other pieces.
But let's be real, they
could've fit a lot more chips
into this packet.
And Lay's is notorious
for filling it with air.
It's actually nitrogen gas,
which helps preserve the chips
and also acts as a cushion
to stop them from getting
smashed in transit.
I mean ...
What would it have been
like without the cushion?
This whole bag would've
been dust, apparently.
But what is the
air-to-chip ratio, you ask?
Let's find out in a new
segment I like to call
the Ar-chip-medes principle.
Can I just say, this is
one of the weirdest things
I've done in my life.
A generous 55 ml of chips in this packet.
Now let's measure how
much the packet itself
can hold in volume.
Score!
Ooh, this smells so bad.
900 ml.
That's 845 ml of chips
that we could have had, Lay's.
I feel cheated.
I think to make it more
accurate, let's do four.
And then we'll fill this guy up,
and then we'll divide by four,
and that would give us
the average of those.
Does that make sense?
Dust.
Uh-huh, all right.
Oh, man. All right.
Can I please have the scientific
chip-crunching nunchucks?
Throw them!
Ah! Whoa!
Look out, chips.
Pow. Pow. Pow.
2.75 fluid ounces per bag.
Now that's science you can use.
So, now we're going to
fill this with water.
Ugh.
The whole thing's 20, which is about 2.75.
17.25 units of whatever.
Cubic fluid ounces?
Even more interesting air information.
Because of India's varied geography,
the amount of air that's
packed into these packets
is different for different altitudes.
For example, in cities of higher altitude,
like Leh in the Himalayas,
there is the risk of
these packets exploding
due to the low atmospheric pressure.
And so, when they're sent there,
they're sent with no air
at all inside of them.
And so they run the risk of
being crushed in transport,
so they have to be taken as
delicately as a crate of eggs.
But what about price?
This is our largest chips
packet, the 174 grams.
And on Swiggy and Amazon, this
sells for about 78 rupees,
which is about a dollar right now.
And that equals ...
rupees 0.44 per gram.
About $0.005.
And, yes, I did all of that
math and conversion in my head.
Here in the US, if we break it down
starting with this big bag,
the 226.8 gram, aka 8-ounce, bag,
it's $3.99 at Target,
or 316.58 rupees.
Yes, it's a bigger bag, I know.
So breaking it down per gram,
we found that in the US,
the cost is a 260%
increase compared to India.
While we do enjoy our Lay's chips,
we also have a giant chip
culture here in India.
In fact, these are called hot chips,
and they're sold all across India
at stalls called hot-chip stalls,
where, basically, they
have a giant frying pan,
and they cut the potato in front of you
to these thin slices and fry it
and give it to you nice,
hot-hot, fresh-fresh.
And so, for 174 grams,
which is the same as this,
you're paying rupees 45
for a lot fresher chips.
So as you can see, Lay's
is competing against
a giant chip market here in India
and doing pretty well, I would say.
Now for the burning question.
Are there any questionable ingredients
that are in your Lay's chips
that you need to watch out for?
Fret not, because Joe and I
have found them out for you.
As far as the basic salted version goes,
you're totally fine.
Both in India and the US,
they're made of potatoes,
vegetable oil, salt.
Warning! Warning alert!
Here in India, some of our flavors
have an ingredient called
potassium chloride.
In regular doses, this is completely safe,
and it's a low-sodium alternative to salt.
However, it's also one of
the three ingredients used
in the three-drug cocktail
for lethal injections.
Too much potassium chloride
will cause irregular heartbeats,
and, boom, your heart will stop.
So if you've been thinking
of doing a Lay's mukbang,
be careful.
We don't have any of that in the US Lay's,
but we do have food coloring,
caramel color in our barbecue
and honey-barbecue chips.
Certain types of caramel
color can contain a byproduct
called 4-meI.
Studies found that it caused
cancer in rats and mice,
leading campaigns in support
of banning it from foods.
Give me that dancing rat!
All right. The FDA was
like, "Meh, it's fine.
Humans don't come close
to the level of exposure
that caused the rat tumors."
But that didn't stop
the state of California
adding it to its Proposition
65 list of chemicals, quote,
"known to the state of
California to cause cancer
or reproductive toxicity," end quote. Oof.
Another ingredient found
in several varieties
of Lay's chips here in
India is disodium glutamate,
aka flavor enhancer 69.
No, not 69.
Flavor enhancer 627.
But basically, it's used alongside MSG
to enhance the flavor of the chips.
Both the Food and Drug Administration,
or the FDA, in the United States,
and the European Food Safety
Authority, or the EFSA,
consider disodium glutamate safe.
But it's not recommended
for babies, children,
pregnant women, and lactating mothers,
and also should be avoided by asthmatics
or people suffering from gout.
MSG, if you're wondering,
is the commonly misunderstood ingredient
known as monosodium glutamate
which is added to a lot of Asian cuisine
and gives it that umami flavor.
In 2019, Lay's sued a
bunch of Indian farmers
for growing a certain variety
of potato, FC5 variety,
saying it has a patent on that variety.
This type of potato is
ideal for snack chips,
as it has a lower moisture content.
But strike one up for the little guy.
Farmers'-rights activists
petitioned to the
Protection of Plant Varieties
and Farmers' Rights Authority,
and it agreed.
PepsiCo, Lay's, cannot claim
a patent over a seed variety.
It was revoked immediately,
and the Indian potato
farmers are now flush
with low-moisture-potato money.
Let's go!
So, which country has
the unhealthiest chips?
Let's compare the classics first.
A 28-gram bag of classic Lay's in the US
contains 160 calories,
10 grams of total fat,
1.5 grams of saturated
fat, 15 grams of carbs,
and 170 milligrams of sodium.
OK, so our Lay's nutrition
is per 100 grams.
So I did a little bit of math
to compare it to the US 28 grams.
Actually, Joe did the math.
So if the math is wrong, blame Joe.
OK, so we have 154.8 calories,
total fat, 9.8 grams,
of which saturates are 3.7 grams,
carbs are 14.7 grams,
and sodium, 142.8 milligrams.
Wow, that was pretty close, actually.
We're under the US in every metric
except for saturated fats,
where we are over 164%.
And I think that's because
we use palm-olein oil
to fry our chips, and it's
very high in saturated fats,
unlike the US vegetable oil.
What about the least-healthiest
chip in each country?
Over here, there are a lot of them
that are tied to 160
calories per 28-gram bag.
Show list.
But we did find that the 160-calorie chips
with the highest fat content are these.
No!
The cheddar and sour
cream, I love these guys.
Making them the least healthy.
If I did have a bag that small,
it would contain all of this.
And here in India, our
highest-calorific chip is
classic salted.
How lame.
How is this the most calorific
chip we sell here, Lay's?
If I had to run an extra mile,
it wouldn't be for classic salted.
So you know what the next
most-calorific chip is?
Magic masala, baby.
Blue Lay's.
We had to end with this one.
Super calorific.
I don't know why I'm
proud of that, but good.
Great to know that this
is and forever will be
the maharaja of Lay's.
Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Taco Bell in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in India, our typical
tacos come in orders of one;
two, in a two-taco meal
with fries and a drink;
three, taco-trio combo,
which comes with nachos and a drink;
or, on weekends, they have a special offer
where you can get eight tacos
in their weekend taco party extravaga --
what's it called?
Taco, taco, t --
Eight weekend party pack taco ...
Eight-taco weekend party pack!
Have a party with your friends.
Only if there are eight of them
and they all are OK with
having just one taco.
In the US, our standard Taco Bell tacos
come in orders of one,
three with a drink,
and the 12-taco box.
12 tacos, one box.
How you doing?
Here in India, our classic
burrito is 16.5 centimeters,
or 6.5 inches.
Our US burrito is 5 inches across.
In terms of girth -- this is
the first time I've measured
the girth of anything, promise.
7 inches.
Joe: Also about 5 inches.
And that's what matters most.
OK, now to measure the weight
of our classic burrito.
Damn!
This is a big boy.
291 grams.
Joe: 185 grams.
Our classic quesadilla
is just shy of 11 inches.
Joe: 10 inches.
And as for weight, boop, boop, boop, boop.
And it weighs 174 grams.
Joe: 202 grams.
At an Indian Taco Bell, the
largest item we have on our menu
is the aforementioned
weekend eight-taco party
picnic popping what
the f--- is this thing?
Eight-taco weekend party
pack, and it's always a party.
So, the vegetarian version is 499 rupees,
and the non-vegetarian
version is 599 rupees.
In the US, our biggest menu item
is the supreme variety taco party pack.
It is 12 supreme tacos,
and it runs $21.99,
or 1,751.65 Indian rupee.
Here's everything you'll
find at a Taco Bell in India
that you will not find in the US.
And here is everything at a US Taco Bell
you can't find in India.
Let's taco about it.
Here in India, all of the
tacos have a vegetarian option.
It's because even though
India is a primarily
non-vegetarian country,
we have a huge population of vegetarians
or people who have different preferences
of what kind of meat they like to eat.
And so it's great for most
of these fast-food chains
to have a lot of veg options.
All of them have the option
of either pinto beans,
fajita veggies, or Mexican paneer,
and they're also in
increasing order of spice.
The cheesy double-decker taco.
Honestly, I actually
really like this taco.
I know it's sacrilege for some people
to eat a soft-shell and a
hard-shell taco together,
but when you parcel this stuff
and get it delivered to you,
both the tacos become soft shell.
Really yum.
All right, the next taco I'm
going to eat is a crunchy taco,
plain and simple. It's
got pinto beans in it.
[sighs] It's unfair to
dis on a crunchy taco
after you've ordered it from
a restaurant that's far away,
because look at this.
It's become soggy already.
So I'm going to be gentle
on my criticism of this.
But you, you soft-shell
tacos are getting it, huh?
There's still some decent crunch to it.
Here in India, pinto beans
are what we call rajma,
and they're a staple.
We f---ing love our rajma.
So it's a perfect match
to put them in a taco.
Next up, another crunchy taco.
This one is the Mexican paneer.
Now, paneer, if you're
unaware, is cottage cheese.
We make it all over here in India.
We basically curdle milk,
add some sort of fruit
or vegetable acid to it,
like lemon juice,
and you get cottage
cheese, which is paneer.
I'm curious to know
what makes this Mexican.
Paneer is one of the most
popular things you'll find
in India at any restaurant.
This paneer tastes chalky,
like most processed paneer
that you'd store in a freezer would.
If you prefer your paneer chunky,
you might enjoy this.
Me, not so much.
Now on to the soft-shell tacos.
This one is Mexican paneer,
the same thing I just had.
This Mexican paneer is
a little bit more spicy.
My favorite thing about tacos is that
not every bite is uniform,
so you get a lot of
different textures and
flavors in each bite you take,
and I guess that's proving
its point over here.
OK, so the next one we're going to try
is a soft taco with fajita veggies inside.
I'm opting out of the fajita veggies
as a filling in general.
And finally we have
our last veggie option,
which is a veggie fiesta,
which has tater tots.
Win. That's a win.
If I was going to Taco Bell
and had to order a veggie
taco for some reason,
my option would be a
crunchy pinto bean taco.
And now for our non-vegetarian tacos.
Please note that all of
the meat in our tacos
is chicken and not beef.
This is because we have a
huge percentage of Hindus
here in India, and they do not eat beef.
This makes all of our
non-veg tacos exclusives!
Because, yes, in the US
you can substitute your beef for chicken,
but it's not on the
official menu, all right?
It's a modification,
which means these are
more exclusives to India.
OK, so you have two options of filling,
either Mexican chicken or grilled chicken.
We're starting off with a
grilled-chicken crunchy taco,
which has severely disintegrated.
Not bad. This is also kind of the test
of Taco Bell's structural integrity.
Pretty good.
That's a win from me. What
else do you want, Taco Bell?
This taco, though, has seen better times.
It kind of reminds me of a rajma chawal.
And when you're chewing on a rajma chawal,
that's how soft the chicken is.
There are a lot of
comparisons you can make
with Mexican and Indian food.
We have something exactly
like this in India.
It's called a chapati, and
it's made out of wheat.
The tortillas in Mexico are
typically made with corn.
The one in Taco Bell is made out of maida,
which is all-purpose flour.
I can't speak for Mexican cuisine,
but there's definitely a lot
of Indian flavors in this.
This is actually a soft
grilled-chicken taco,
and I can wholeheartedly
say worst of the bunch.
Don't get this one.
A cheese double-decker taco
with grilled chicken again.
Come on, man. I wanted the Mexican one.
But the hard-shell taco
is disintegrating into a soft-shell taco.
It's nothing special.
Chicken fiesta taco.
Oh, my God!
I didn't expect that at all.
I've just been chewing
for so long. I'm so tired.
Oh, damn. The aftertaste
of this is really good.
There's a lot of nice spice to it.
Now we have a very special taco.
As you can see, this one is still wrapped,
because I've never seen this in my life.
It's called a naked chicken taco.
Pause for a moment.
What do you think that means?
Oh,
my
God.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the naked chicken taco.
Crew: Whoo! [applauding]
Genuinely feels like
I just undressed food.
So, there's no chicken filling inside it
because the chicken is the taco!
That's right. That's how far
we have come as the human race.
We have taken this bird and
turned it into a freaking
pancake and folded it over cheese!
Your scientists were too
busy trying to figure out
whether they could do it.
They didn't stop to think
whether they should do it.
I think that might be one
of the worst things I've had
on this show.
Oh, God. Oh, God.
I'm gonna be honest, it actually
looks pretty good to me.
That reminds me of the KFC double down,
which I did actually enjoy. I'd try it.
Starting off, soft taco
and soft Taco Supreme,
which is beef.
Flimsiest thing in the world.
Ew!
This stuff is, oh, this stuff
is sweating already. Ugh.
So, I don't know how many
vegetarians are watching now,
but ... look at what you're missing?
I think I just created a few vegetarians.
I mean, I like how they taste,
but, I mean, Taco Bell's got
so much fun stuff on the menu.
What are you doing eating regular tacos?
Like, get out of here.
Crunchy taco, which we saw earlier.
Fantastic.
A little more stuff in it,
the beef Supreme Taco.
They really load it up with the veggies.
India. India. India!
Look at me.
This is my favorite thing
in the Taco Bell menu.
I sing its praises at every
Taco Bell "Food Wars."
It is the nacho cheese
Doritos locos tacos.
Some genius somewhere
connected Taco Bell and Doritos
to make a hard-shell taco that
is, in fact, a Doritos shell.
Mm.
Comes in standard and, of course, supreme.
This, I've been looking
forward to this all day.
It's burrito time, baby!
I've gotten a Mexican paneer version here
as well as a pinto beans version.
I think I'll go with the pinto beans one.
By the way, this tray is all
of the vegetarian burritos,
and this is the non-vegetarian tray.
Happy baby.
India has a lot of roll culture.
We have kati rolls, we have Kolkata rolls,
we also have shawarmas,
which we are a huge fan of.
Most Indians, this
basically will feel like
you took rajma rice and you
shoved it inside a maida roti.
I think I'd go with a taco over this.
Next up, we have tikka masala.
But, I found this out recently,
it was actually invented by the British.
So, clearly inspired by
India, but invented by them.
Another thing that the
British took from us
that we haven't been paid back for.
We have a flavor here
which is called achari,
and it's basically like a pickle.
This is more achari than
chicken-tikka-masala-y.
Also, I would be lying if I
didn't admit that, Taco Bell,
it's already doing its thing
to my digestive system.
Taco Bell is notorious for
making you go to the bathroom.
Zoom in to my stomach
right now and just listen
to the noises, and
let's get a translation.
[farting]
♪ Oh, my God ♪
And now for Sriracha veg burrito.
It's now running the risk
of offending three different cultures.
I don't normally eat a
burrito by ripping it in half.
Actually, that sounds awesome.
We should do that more often.
Like, a double-handed --
don't clip that.
Hm. You can skip it.
We have the seven-layer burrito.
This one tastes like all
of these put together.
And we have one last veg wrap.
Ah, guys, I can't do this.
It's the same thing!
It's just tater tots, that same filling.
I bow down in defeat, Taco Bell.
You have vanquished me.
Moving on to the non-vegetarian burritos,
and we're hoping some of these
are a little more
distinct from the others.
All right, we have a classic
Mexican chicken burrito.
This is so bad.
This is damn bad.
Let's just say I'm glad
you didn't call yourself
burrito bowl.
Next up, tikka masala, but now in non-veg.
["Piano Man" harmonica playing]
This is actually quite good!
This one doesn't taste as dry
as the other ones I've had.
And, of course, we have the seven-layer
non-vegetarian burrito.
Instead of paneer, we
have grilled chicken.
Let's just do the slap test again.
Oof.
Yeah, you could really hurt somebody
with the seven-layer one.
OK, we have one last burrito, which is --
wait, what is this?
This is not -- why have you done this?
This burrito looks like the love child
of all other burritos over here.
These burritos are definitely
related, and this is
the product of incest.
[baby cries]
Wow, it's actually not that bad.
Honestly, out of all of these,
I'd prefer to finish this one
because it's just smaller.
The pain will end faster.
Burritos.
Might not be visually the most exciting
part of the video, but please don't leave.
Maybe just open some clips
of "Family Guy" next to it,
so you can watch that and
this like you're on TikTok.
The double steak grilled cheese burrito
and the spicy double steak
grilled cheese burrito.
And, right, it's grilled
cheese 'cause they
grill it shut with cheese.
Genius idea.
Yeah! Look at that, it
has jalapeños on it.
Oh, that's fantastic.
That's a really great idea.
Oh. Yeah, this rules.
A beefy quesarito.
When these things cool off, though,
it's just a lot of cheese in there.
Oh, and it has rice in it.
Well, burritos have rice,
I don't know why I'm so surprised by that.
Rice in a burrito?!
Same thing but with black beans.
I mean, it's already kind of
dripping out there already.
Grilled No. 1, beans and
cheese in there, you see that?
And the red is those chips.
They put those crispy chips in there.
Five-layer burrito.
It used to be seven-layer.
Took out two layers and added a beefy one
for some weird reason.
I assure you there's five
layers and beef inside this.
No, I'm not doing that. I'm not
some weird fetish that on the internet
that I'm not aware of,
slapping faces with burritos.
Burrito Supreme.
Look, it's so much different
from the last thing we
were just looking at.
But that one's just like ...
"CK," Chipotle chicken.
Yeah, chipotle mayo's legit.
I got an extra one, if anyone wants it.
Go ahead and comment below,
and I'll mail it to you.
Beefy melt.
Beef and melted cheese.
I can't believe it!
Together at last!
I mean, it tastes like all the other ones.
Feel like we could pare
this menu down a little bit.
Last and not least, cheesy bean and rice.
Now for India's specialities.
I am excited for the diversity.
That's all I'll say.
Very representative of our country.
Let's start off with the chalupa.
The humble chalupa
is nice.
If you guys are at home wondering
what the difference between a
normal taco and a chalupa is,
you should Google it.
What is this, an education show?
I'm just here to eat, man.
For my Indian brethren,
it's kind of the difference
between a chapati and a patuda.
They actually fry it a little bit.
Mm, mm, mm!
But that was a very
horrible place to bite,
because I only got chicken.
I have a soft spot for the
chalupa, and it gets my approval.
We have the vegstar wrap.
Voilà.
So inventive. Let's take a
burrito but make it flat.
Oh, wow.
Don't make me eat this, Insider, please.
Ugh!
I'm coming from a country
where we're used to eating
something like this, a chapati,
with a sabzi on the side,
which is a curry which has vegetables
and fresh paneer and maybe some chicken.
So to eat something like this
just feels not even subpar,
it just feels wrong.
I'm actually curious to know
if any Mexicans watching this video
can let me know in the comments
whether you feel like
Taco Bell has done justice
to representing your cuisine in any way.
Next up, we have a chickstar.
Round of applause.
[crickets chirping]
I'm just going to keep this
UFO of man's worst
accomplishment over here.
Quesadilla, fajita veg.
Very thin.
Curious to know how they have fit
a lot of fajita veggies into it.
They haven't.
How do people do this?
My God. I just realized,
Joe is insane.
How have you eaten so much Taco Bell, Joe?
Yeah, I'm insane.
I lost my mind somewhere
during the Japan season.
Oh well.
And it's strange, 'cause
I'm still an intern.
We're doing rice bowls now.
Ugh!
Yeah, it looks really good
if it was abstract art in a museum
about 20 meters away from your eyeballs.
But when you come close
and then you're faced
with the proposition of eating it,
ugh!
I can feel my body rejecting this.
Otherwise, it's fine.
I mean, it's just very average.
It's just a normal rice bowl.
We have the same thing, another rice bowl,
but this time it's got some
grilled chicken in there.
That was really good.
This feels like the safest bet.
Ah! I don't know what anything is still.
So let's go through it together.
The first thing,
this is either a black bean
chalupa or a dirty diaper.
I can't tell.
'Cause it's thick and wrinkly
and just dripping with black goo.
Don't want that.
Oh! It's this, yeah!
I mean, every time these
Doritos shells show up,
I'm just happy.
Dorito cheesy gordita crunch nacho cheese.
They put every word in that.
Oh, it's that thing, but not nacho'd.
Once you have the Doritos shell version,
to go back is like, no way. No way!
I've touched the sky.
I can stay on the ground no longer.
And then we have two
Crunchwrap Supreme options,
black bean Crunchwrap Supreme,
and then the regular Crunchwrap Supreme
is, of course, filled with beef.
OK, it's time now for India's sides menu,
starting off with Mexican corn salad.
You don't need to add so much sauce to it.
I feel like this could've
been a lot simpler,
and people would appreciate it more.
Next up, we have loaded
fries and loaded nachos.
So, typically, Taco Bell
does not serve loaded nachos
and loaded fries here in India,
but we found a restaurant
that was kind enough
to send it to us anyways.
I will say, this is
probably my favorite thing
about Taco Bell in India.
The loaded nachos are banging,
when you get them at the restaurant.
Oy.
But, yeah, there's a reason
they don't deliver it.
That tastes like wet cardboard.
And now we have two barf bags.
Just kidding.
Chicken nachos.
They had chicken tacos, and
now there are chicken nachos.
And our second doggy bag has -- whoa!
That was alarming. Because
what I saw was this.
I did not expect this
to come out of that bag.
Crispy chicken strips.
Sides, baby.
We got 'em.
Cheesy fiesta potatoes.
There's better things
to be had on the menu,
but I do like those.
Black beans, black beans and rice,
and you can get a guacamole side.
Now, here are some
items that are available
both in India and the US
but are still very different.
For example,
this is India's quesadilla,
grilled cheese quesadilla.
But as you can see,
it's filled with a lot of fajita veggies,
it's got this special creamy sauce,
and it's topped with a lot of jalapeños.
Whereas in the US, it
comes with just cheese.
How boring is that?
Correct. And this is what it looks like.
Incredibly boring.
Another big difference is here in India,
our nachos are all seasoned,
so they already have a masala
or some sort of spice to them.
Our nacho chips in the US are
just regular tortilla chips
with nacho cheese.
Here in India, in our veg options,
we use pinto beans, or rajma.
Whereas in the US, our bean
of choice is the black bean.
Exclusive US sauces.
Hey, you know what that means.
Sauce talk.
It's now time for
India's exclusive sauces.
We have quite the wide range.
We have cool ranch.
Because there's a lot of spice
in a lot of these burritos and tacos,
I imagine if you're somebody
who can't tolerate spice,
definitely get a side of this.
Then there is spicy salsa.
I tasted it. It's really nice.
It's got a lot more spice to it,
but also the flavor of
imli, which is tamarind.
We use it in a lot of our dishes,
especially South Indian dishes.
Then there's a chocolate sauce,
which I imagine is for churros
or some sort of dippable dessert.
But if you want to dip
your quesadilla into this,
I'm not going to judge.
Next up we have lava sauce,
which doesn't really
look as much like lava,
but it definitely has a kick to it.
Chicken tikka masala sauce,
which looks more like lava.
Down in the end here we
got reduced-fat sour cream.
Who doesn't like chips
and sour cream, right?
Could use some fat.
Then, moving on, we have a chipotle sauce.
Chipotle sauce is very good.
Mm. Mm. Mm. Mm.
Avocado ranch.
Mm!
I love it. More of that, please.
And they have a spicy ranch.
How spicy could it be?
Not very.
And finally, the red sauce.
OK, it is finally dessert time.
I've eaten a lot of savory food,
and I'm excited for the desserts.
Good old churros.
I am a big fan of churros.
They send you one chocolaty dip.
I feel like you can't
really go wrong with churros
if you want to call yourself a restaurant.
And next is something I
have never seen before.
Cinnamon twisties.
I could see myself, you
know, at 3 a.m. in the night,
sad, vulnerable, eating
a whole packet of these.
So that means it's a good dessert.
Taco Bell used to sell quesadillas
filled with chocolate, and
they were called chocodillas.
But I guess they've stopped that now.
Taco Bell is against puns.
The only US exclusive
dessert we have are these,
the Cinnabon Delights.
As Cinnabons, I'm pretty
sure this is filled
with some sort of cream cheese, right?
I assure you there's cream cheese in this
or whatever, their frosting.
Someone's got to eat it. That
definitely can't go to waste.
Eat it now!
Right? They're fantastic.
All right, it's time for
India's exclusive drinks.
What could we do without them?
Nothing. I would've choked to death
on all that burrito maida wrap.
First up, the soft drinks that we have,
we sell 7Up and Mirinda over here,
but actually in Bengaluru
I've seen a lot more variety of drinks.
So I think it varies from store to store.
Next up, Taco Bell sells juices.
This one was a mixed fruit juice,
but I drank it all,
and I can tell you, it was pretty good.
They also sell a
cranberry and apple juice,
but the stores that we asked in Mumbai
did not have those available.
And finally, they sell milkshakes.
This is mango. This is
chocolate. Cookie crumble.
The true test of a milkshake
is to test the fruit one
and see if it's still fresh.
Hey, that's pretty good.
The mango milkshake.
US exclusive drinks.
There's literally a million,
yes, really, of soft drinks
you can get at Taco Bell
you can't get in India.
So I just went and got a diet Pepsi
and, of course,
[clown horn honking]
Baja Blast.
After doing this, what, three,
four times at this point,
I'm actually starting to like Baja Blast.
You can actually get a
whole bunch of soft drinks
at the US Taco Bell.
♪ All of these ♪
I wasn't getting 20 drinks.
Get yourself a bottle, OJ, Tropicana.
Also something you can get
are things called freezes,
which at one point were frozen
slushy- or Slurpee-like drinks.
You can get, of course, a
Mountain Dew Baja Blast.
And also get yourself wild cherry freeze.
Oh, f---.
That's cough syrup.
Also, you can get coffee,
both iced and hot.
Iced coffee.
Oh, no, wait, that's soda. What is this?
Ignore that. Put that over there.
The Cinnabon Delight coffee.
OK, so they accidentally
gave us two of these.
Iced coffee that's flavored
like the Cinnabon Delights.
Are you kidding me?
I can just feel my life expectancy
just getting closer and closer.
Just like, sip, mm,
he ain't seeing his 80s, mm.
But it's worth it. That's delicious.
You can also get those coffees hot.
Taco Bell breakfast, baby.
I think this is just about everything.
Once again, I can't tell what anything is.
It's all just a sea of beige.
Let's find out together.
This one just says bacon.
Thank you for that.
Burrito with bacon.
I'm like the Riddler over here.
Just like, hey, figure it out.
Question mark, question mark.
I mean, it's a bit unnatural
how yellow that is.
It's really bright. It's a bit concerning.
This one's going to be the
one with steak, I assume.
Yeah. [laughs] Who's hungry?
The steak's a little weird.
Maybe don't get the
steak one specifically.
Do you see this condensation?
How bad this food is sweating?
Breakfast Crunchwrap Supreme.
Oh, there's sausage inside of this.
Look, comes inside.
It's like the magic ticket.
Now I get to work at
Taco Bell or something.
Their sausage is good, though.
Get yourself a hash brown.
They also have breakfast salsa,
but the Taco Bell I went
to did not have any.
Let's talk about nutrition,
everybody's favorite topic.
That's why you come to "Food Wars,"
'cause you love fast food,
but mainly, you love nutrition.
In India, a typical soft-shell
Mexican chicken taco
will be 185 calories.
In the US, our standard chicken
soft taco is 160 calories.
So we have fewer calories,
fat, carbs, and sodium,
but more protein.
Next up is the chicken quesadilla.
Ours has 268.5 calories.
And ours is 510 calories.
Now, please note the sodium
level on our quesadilla.
It's over half the daily
recommended amount.
That's a salty quesadilla.
In India, a vegstar
wrap is 239.9 calories.
Closest we have to that is our
black bean Crunchwrap Supreme.
Again, double the calorie count,
get a load of that sodium.
Are you looking for the most
calorific item here in India?
Well, look no further
than the cinnamon twists!
Each of these packets will
cost you 480.9 calories!
Here in the US, if
you're having a hard time
finding calories at a
Taco Bell, check out this.
The double beef grilled cheese burrito.
So, Taco Bell in India does not disclose
any of their ingredients,
but I thought it would be interesting
to talk about two of the ingredients
that we have here that
are unique to India.
No. 1 is paneer.
So, the problem with the Mexican paneer
that was served to me in
this batch of Taco Bell
is that it tasted like
the processed paneer you get at stores.
It tasted like something that
had been stored in the fridge.
Also, because paneer is
so popular here in India,
every single fast-food
restaurant has paneer options.
You know, when you know
how well it can be done,
I didn't like the paneer that much
in the burritos and tacos I had today.
The next ingredient I want to
talk about is tikka masala.
I thought it was OK.
It had a lot of flavor.
It was quite spicy.
But the thing that makes
tikka masala so exciting
is that it's always made
from fresh tomatoes.
And so you can sort of
tell there's a difference
when it's in the sauce form.
However, I will say it's
always a valiant effort
to see these fast-food companies
and people who come here
from abroad in general
adapt to the Indian palate
and try to make cuisine that matches ours.
In the US, we do disclose our ingredients,
and here's a few you should be wary of.
First is brominated
vegetable oil, aka BVO.
BVO is an emulsifier found
in citrus-flavored sodas
that specifically use citrus oils,
and it's considered a health risk
when ingested in large amounts.
In one case, a man who drank
2 to 4 liters of BVO soda per day
developed bromism and experienced symptoms
such as memory loss and
extreme muscle fatigue.
It can be found in the
ingredients of three
of the cantina-menu freezes:
the beach berry freeze,
the ginger mule freeze,
and the party punch freeze.
The last one, the party punch freeze,
also contains yellow
No. 5, aka tartrazine,
which is subject to
restriction outside the US
in places like the EU and India,
as it, quote, "may have an
adverse effect on activity
and attention in children."
And you can find it in
several Taco Bell menu items,
specifically the Doritos locos
taco nacho cheese shells,
oh, no! I had, like, three of those today.
And Baja Blast,
gah! Just when I was starting to like it.
I just want to shout
out Joe Avella and say
I understand what trauma
you must be going through
after doing so many Taco Bell episodes.
You're a brave, brave man, Joe.